Happy New Year, everyone.
大家新年快乐。
Josh and Craig here.
我是Josh和Craig。
We are taking this week off to ring in the New Year, but we don't want to leave you without an episode to ring it in with.
我们这周休息，去迎接新年，但我们不想让大家在没有剧集的情况下跨年。
So we are replaying, repeating, re...
所以我们决定重播、重复、重……
We just, it's a rerun, let's just call it.
反正就是重播，我们直说吧。
Let's say what it is.
我们就实话实说吧。
We don't want to disrespect you on this.
我们不想在这件事上敷衍大家。
We're rerunning a great episode from season one called The Limo.
我们重播第一季中精彩的一集，剧名叫《豪华轿车》。
We hope you enjoy it.
希望大家喜欢。
We loved revisiting this episode.
我们非常喜欢重温这一集。
episode.
这一集。
It was hard to shoot.
当时拍摄起来很困难。
We remember.
我们还记得。
But it turned out great.
但成片效果很棒。
And what else?
还有什么呢？
What else to say about the limo, Craig?
Craig，关于这辆豪华轿车还有什么要说的吗？
It's one of our own.
这是我们自己的剧集之一。
I mean, it's, we didn't do any years of episode every year.
我是说，我们并没有每年都拍一季。
I don't think we had one season two, for example.
比如，我不觉得我们拍过第二季。
So it's kind of it's cool.
所以这感觉很酷。
It's I love this one very much, not Moby.
我非常喜欢这一集，不是Moby那个。
There are so many things in this episode.
这一集里有很多看点。
It's our only episode.
这是我们唯一的一集。
I think that takes place almost exclusively in a limo, which we thought would be easy to shoot and was a nightmare to shoot.
我觉得它几乎全程发生在豪华轿车里，我们本以为会很好拍，结果却是一场噩梦。
So please enjoy us, remembering what a nightmare it was to shoot and the amazing episode came out of it.
所以请欣赏我们回顾当时拍摄的噩梦，以及最终诞生的精彩剧集。
Hi guys, my name is Andrea, I'm from Mexico and I really do love the episode about the limo.
大家好，我是Andrea，来自墨西哥，我真的很喜欢关于豪华轿车的那一集。
I've actually watched it every single New Year's Eve right after 12th and honestly the funny thing is New Year's Eve is like my least favorite holiday of all but I don't know this episode just says to me what's important about a holiday you know like it's not about what party you go to or about gifts or about you know make it extraordinary but about the people you actually spend it with about reflecting about being thankful for one another and I don't know I guess that's just one of the things that I love the most about the show that it makes you come back to the people you love and making sure you spend the most time as possible.
实际上，我每年除夕夜12点过后都会看一遍。老实说，有趣的是，除夕夜是我最不喜欢的节日，但我不知道为什么，这一集向我传达了节日真正重要的东西。它不是关于你去了什么派对，也不是关于礼物，或者让它变得多么非凡，而是关于和你一起度过的人，关于反思，关于彼此感恩。我不知道，我想这就是我最喜欢这个剧的原因之一，它让你回到你爱的人身边，确保你尽可能多地花时间。
You can with them and cherish each other.
和他们在一起，珍惜彼此。
Thank you so much for doing this podcast.
非常感谢你们制作这个播客。
This is amazing.
这太棒了。
So thank you and thank you for changing my life for the better.
所以谢谢你们，感谢你们让我的生活变得更美好。
I'm alone, won't be soon.
我孤身一人，但很快就不会了。
You know York City, when I see you.
你知道纽约市，当我见到你时。
Please permit me to tell you everything, York City.
请允许我告诉你一切，纽约市。
Well, hello, welcome to another episode of How We Made Your Mother.
大家好，欢迎收听《老爸老妈罗曼史》的又一集。
I'm Josh Radner and I am joined by my friend Craig Thomas.
我是Josh Radner，我的朋友Craig Thomas也加入了我们。
Hello, Craig.
你好，Craig。
Hey, Josh.
嘿，Josh。
Hi.
嗨。
I almost cry every time at the openings now.
我现在每次听到片头曲都快哭了。
I know.
我知道。
I'm going to produce your aliquets together.
我真的每次都快要哭出来了。
I literally almost start to cry every time.
Andrea，我当时想，这太美了。
Andrea, I kind of thought, it's so beautiful.
我们直接播放那封信就好了。
We could just play that letter.
那在某种程度上几乎就是这一集的全部了。
It's like, that's pretty much the episode in some way.
她总结得很到位。
She summed it up.
感谢大家收听今天的节目。
So thank you for joining us on today's episode.
这应该是最短的一集。
It was just to be the shortest one.
如果你刚收听，刚才那封来自墨西哥Andrea的信，我非常喜欢。
So if you're just tuning in, Andrea from Mexico, which I just love that letter.
Andrea，非常感谢你。
Thank you so much for that, Andrea.
她谈论的是《老爸老妈罗曼史》第11集。
She was talking about episode 11 of how I met your mother.
我总是搞混标题。
I'm getting confused about titles.
就像我说的，标题总是很棘手。
Like I say, how I made your mother, made your mother very tricky.
但在这个播客里，我们正在进行重温。
But on this podcast, we are doing a rewatch.
我在剧中扮演Ted Mosby，从2005年到2014年？
I played Ted Mosby on the show from, what was it, 2005 to 2014?
我出演了每一集。
I was in every single episode.
Craig Thomas可能有一两句台词，或者在很多集里有每一句台词。
Craig Thomas probably had a line or two, or every line in many of the episodes.
他是该剧的联合创作者。
He co-created the show.
我在剧里贡献了两个笑话。
I got in two jokes in the series.
他贡献了两个笑话。
He got in two jokes.
我贡献了两个笑话。
I got two jokes.
他和Carter Bayes共同创作了这部剧。
He co-created the show with Carter Bayes.
我们正在回顾这一过程，探索这部剧为何能长盛不衰，为什么人们如此喜爱它，为什么人们会在每个除夕夜观看豪华轿车那一集，以及这部剧对人们产生了什么影响，并仍在产生影响。
And we're working our way through it, and we're unpacking this mystery of why the show has endured, why people love it so much, why people watch the limo episode every New Year's Eve and what the show just has done to people and continues to do.
但在开始之前，Craig，我们要讨论第11集豪华轿车。
But before we started, we start today, Craig, talking about the limo episode 11.
我确实想做一个简短的年度总结，我想问你，制作这个播客对你来说感觉如何？
I did want to do a little State of the Union and I just wanted to ask you, how's it going doing this podcast for you?
哦，我喜欢它。
Oh, I love it.
你选择做年度总结的时机太完美了，因为这是22集里的第11集，几乎所有的季度都是22集或24集。
And you've chosen the perfect moment to do State of the Union because this is episode 11 out of 22, almost all of the seasons were either 22 episodes or 24, 24 in success.
一旦我们火了，他们就会要求增加集数。
Once we became sort of more of a hit, they're like, give us a couple extra a year.
那是好兆头，当增加到24集的时候。
And that was a very good sign when I went out to 24.
有一年因为2007年的编剧罢工，只有20集。
And one year because of the writer's strike in 2007, it was only 20.
但现在我们正好处于中点，我非常喜欢。
But so right now we're at the exact midpoint and I am loving it.
我已经好几年没看这些剧集了，能够观看并与粉丝分享，听到像我们刚才播放的精彩片头，听到它对人们的意义，我觉得非常感人。
I have not watched a lot of these episodes in years, getting to watch it and sort of share it with fans and here like we just did that amazing opening of this episode, here what it means to people, I just find it's so moving.
我感觉自己像个不同的人在观看。
It's just, I feel like I'm watching it, I feel like a different person watching it.
制作时我深陷其中，离得太近了。
I was so close to it when we were making it.
我当时有着完全不同的视角，我现在很享受，真的非常享受。
I saw it through such different eyes and I'm loving it, I'm loving it.
这太美妙了，而且我惊叹于我们20年前所做的一切，对吧？
It's wonderful and sort of, I'm marveling at what we did 20 years ago, right?
我甚至有点不敢相信。
I can't sort of can't believe a lot of it.
我在想，我们当时是怎么做到的？
I'm like, how do we do that?
我们当时根本不知道自己在干什么。
We didn't know what we're doing.
我想当你深陷其中，在制作后六周剧集就播出时，我的虚荣心与现在完全不同。
I think when you're in it and you're close to it and an episode's airing six weeks after you just made it, for me, my ego was just tied up in it in a different way than it is now.
我现在以更宽容的态度观看，惊叹于我竟然参与了这部迷人的剧集，它至今仍在取悦观众。
I watch it with so much more forgiveness and I'm marveling at the fact that I was involved in this charming show that continues to delight people.
我刚才跟你说过，我刚结束巡演回来，遇到了很多人，比如昨晚餐馆的服务员对我说，我的幽默感都是从你身上学来的。
And I just told you, I've just gotten back from the one leg of my tour And I'm meeting all of these people who, you know, just the waitress at the restaurant I was at last night said, I got my whole sense of humor from you.
你说的是真的吗？
It's your wish you don't.
她说得很认真，太酷了。
That's what you said, that's so cool.
我说，那让我看看你学到了什么。
I said, well, let's see what you got.
我会评判一下的。
I'll be the judge of that.
没错，来吧。
Yeah, let's do it.
但我在想，有时人们往往会轻视电视。
But, you know, I was thinking sometimes, I think that there's a tendency to dismiss TV.
我也犯过这种错，认为它是一种流行媒介。虽然我认为现在有很多像小说一样高质量的电视作品。
And I've been guilty of this too, as a kind of a popular medium that maybe, well, I think there's been so much quality television in almost novelistic ways.
比如《火线》、《黑道家族》，电视确实被提升到了高级艺术的地位，但它也是一种大众媒介，对吧？
Our show, The Wire, The Sopranos, like TV has really been elevated to high art, but it's also a populist medium, right?
它进入了每个人的家中，现在甚至在每个人的口袋里。
It's in everyone's home and now pockets, living rooms.
但如果你思考我们人类对故事的需求，我相信人们在广场上拦截索福克勒斯，我记不清他写了什么，但我明白你的意思。
But if you think about our human need for story, I'm sure people were stopping Sophocles on the street in the Algora or whatever, and being like, I don't remember what he wrote, but you know what I mean?
比如有人说他在禁止吸烟，那是他写的。
Like saying like, I think smoking in the banded too is what he wrote.
我并不是说，阻止一个剧作家在演唱《俄瑞斯忒亚》三部曲时打断他。
Not that I'm saying, you know, stopping a playwright agrees to sing the Orestaya Trilogy really floored me.
但我有一些笔记。
But I've got a few notes.
其实有一个答案给你。
Actually an answer for you.
你能在我的手臂上签名吗，因为我要去纹身。
Can you sign just, yeah, Elektra on my arm, because I'm gonna get a hat to you.
人们确实会要求我在他们手臂上写字，然后他们去纹身。
That's what people want me to write people while they answer on their arms, they get a tattoo.
但我认为有一种人类的渴望，我坚信人们对故事有着某种渴求。
But I think there is a human, I really maintain there's these human ache for stories.
我们需要它们。
We need them.
当人们告诉我，这部剧改变了我的生活，它教我如何与父亲交流，陪我度过离婚，给了我幽默感。
And when people say to me like, this show changed my life, it taught me how to talk with my dad, it got me through my divorce, it gave me my sense of humor.
我现在非常认真地看待这些，我也继续被能够参与其中、以这种方式影响他人而感动。
I take that really seriously now, and I really can't, I continue to be moved to have been a part of something that affected people this way.
但也很奇怪，我和妻子一起看每一集，除了这一集我们是分开的，因为我在巡演。看着那些画面，当你长期在镜头前做某件事时，这种感觉很奇怪。
But I also, you know, it's so strange to be watching this with my wife and watching almost every episode with her, except this episode we were separate, because I was on tour, but just to look back, it's weird when you do something on camera for this long.
这就像是你人生的照片集，两种意义上的移动。
It's almost like you have this weird moving in both senses of the word, like photo album of your life.
这就像是一个奇怪的纪录片快照。
It's like, it's this weird documentary snapshot.
尽管那不是我生活中实际发生的事情，但在某种程度上又是。
And even though that wasn't what was going on in my life, It was partly what was going on in my life.
至少那是我的工作。
At least that was my job.
但大多数人的工作不会被拍摄下来并发布给全世界。
But most people don't have their jobs filmed and then he's out to the rest of the world.
这感觉太奇怪了。
And it feels so weird.
我经常从你的角度思考这次重温。
I think about this from your perspective in this rewatch so often.
我想，Josh记得那天他在哪里。
I'm like, well, Josh knows where he was that day.
那是他从豪华轿车顶部探出头。
That's him popping out of the top of a limo.
那是20年前我人生工作中在那一天做的事情。
He's like, that's what I was doing that day of work of my life 20 years ago.
没人能拥有那种体验，那是你。
No one gets that and that's you.
那是那个年龄、那一分钟、存在于地球上的你，再次观看它时，有一种回到过去的感觉。
That's you at that age, at that minute, existing on planet Earth in that moment and watching it again and kind of going back into that.
比如，我有一种眩晕感，我记得我当时站在拍摄现场的显示器旁看着四个摄像机的画面。
Like, I'm having a little bit of that kind of vertigo of like, I remember I was standing off to the side at Video Village watching the four cameras, you know, the four monitors showing the four camera shots.
那是什么感觉？
But what is it?
这是一种奇怪的情感眩晕吗，试图回想起在豪华轿车里的情景？
Is there kind of like a weird emotional vertigo of trying to like remember your way back into like what it looked like, say within that limo?
我刚刚才意识到。
That just occurred to me.
我记得在公寓或酒吧里时，我们做了太多事，很难单独区分。
I remember, I think sometimes when you're in the apartment or you're in the bar, we did so much in there that it's hard to isolate.
哦，我记得那天，除非发生了特别奇怪的事情。
Oh, I remember that day, unless something really particularly strange happened.
但豪华轿车成了我们共同分享的那个监狱的代名词。
But the limo became shorthand for this prison that we all shared together.
我记得我们说豪华轿车，无论发生什么，我们都会说，至少我们不在车里，因为它太紧张了。
Like, I remember us saying limo, like, whatever was going on, we'd be like, well, at least we're not in the limo because it was so intense.
提醒我一下，它是全在真车里拍摄的，还是为了看起来像豪华轿车而改装的？
And I think, remind me, was it all shot in an actual limo or was some of it tricked out, like, to look like a limo?
我们在摄影棚里拍了一些吗？
Did we shoot some of it on the stage?
我不记得了。
I can't remember.
好吧，Carter当时在片场，他可能比我记得更清楚，真希望他也在。
Well, I, it was an episode that Carter was on the set for and he would probably have more memories than me, so I wish we had him on this one.
但我想，不，我们在拍摄轿车内部。
But I think, no, I think we had, we were shooting the inside of the limo.
我认为很多确实是在那辆车里，我觉得拍摄非常困难。
I think it was, a lot of it was really in that limo, I think, and it was really hard to shoot.
空间太狭窄了。
It was cramped.
我是说，很多时候三人的后座坐了四个人。
I mean, a lot of times there were like four people in like a three-person back seat.
我确实有非常强烈的记忆，有一件事我非常喜欢，那就是天窗部分变成了另一个表演空间。
I did, I do have very strong memories of, one thing I really loved was how the sunroof kind of area becomes this other playing space.
就像另一个房间。
It's like another room.
好吧，就像走上阳台一样，对吧？
Well, it's like stepping out onto the balcony, right?
它有那种感觉，我非常清晰地记得，当从车里出来透透气并探出头时有多快乐，我非常喜欢那上面的所有场景。
Like it has that feel, and I just love, I remember very strongly like when it was joyful to get out of the limo, kind of get some air and pop up, but I really liked all the scenes that were played up there.
我觉得很好，我记得最后与Kobe的那一幕，也许是因为那是第11集，我觉得这一集做得非常好，我们马上会总结一下剧情，但它做得非常好，像我们说的，这是一个独立的集数，你可以随便看，看着这群朋友试图驾驭这个疯狂的除夕夜。
I found it really, and I remember that final scene with Kobe, and maybe it was because it was episode 11, but this episode I think does a very good job, and we'll summarize what the episode is in one second, but it does a very good job of being, like we said, a self-contained episode, you could just tune in and you watch this gang of friends try to navigate this crazy New Year's Eve.
但关于Ted和Robin的事情，你们确实把故事推进了。
But also the Ted and Robin thing, it's like you move the ball down the field.
你们确实做到了你们尝试做的事情。
Like it really does that thing you guys were trying to do.
我觉得你们在这方面做得非常好。
You were having your cake and eating it too, I think in a really nice way here.
是的，在这一集的最结尾，他过马路时信号灯变成了步行，他走进了未来。
Yeah, the very end of that episode where he walks across the street and the light changes to like walk as he walks into kind of the future.
我爱那个镜头。
I love that shot.
首先，Pam Fryman。
First of all, Pam Fryman.
当Pam Fryman安排那样的镜头时，我们称之为“深炸”。
When Pam Fryman would do put together a shot like that, we'd call it, we'd say, that shot was deep fried, the pan-fryment.
那是一个深炸的镜头，它是经典。
And that is a deep fried shot, that is a classic.
感觉他正在走向新的一年。
And it feels like he's walking into a new year.
他正在走进新的一章。
He's walking into a new chapter.
我们不知道会发生什么。
We don't know what's gonna happen.
这是告诉观众“嘿，继续看”的好方法。
It's a great way to say the audience, hey, keep watching.
你们会看到一些很酷的东西。
You're gonna see some cool stuff.
这也是一个纯粹的电影化时刻。
And it's also, it's a purely cinematic moment.
我一直在寻找那样的瞬间，比如我引用我自己的作品，在《校园爱情》中，那是35岁和19岁之间的一段浪漫，但不完全是。
Like I'm always looking for moments, like I'm going to quote, I'm going to reference my own work, but in liberal arts, it's, there's this somewhat of a romance, but not quite between a 35-year-old and a 19-year-old.
他对年龄差异感到痴迷，这是他应有的。
And he's obsessed with their age difference as he should be.
他计算了数学。
And he works out the math.
他说，当我16岁时，她是0岁。
He says, when I was, you know, 16, she was zero.
当我19岁时，她是3岁。
When I was 19, she was three.
但接着他说，那么当我多少岁时，她会是多少岁。
But then he goes, well, when I'm so-and-so she'll be so.
然后年龄差距看起来就不那么是个问题了。
And then the age starts seeming like less of a problem.
但那是一段完全无声的场景。
But it's a totally silent scene.
它来回切换。
And it goes back and forth.
那只是一个特写，页面、页面，以及他的脸，轰，轰，轰。
It's just an inner, a close insert shot on the page a page and his face, boom, boom, boom.
我喜欢的一点是你在剧院里做不到那样。
And the thing I loved about that is you cannot do that in a theater.
那是一个纯粹的电影化镜头。
That is a purely like cinematic shot.
我喜欢豪华轿车的最后一个镜头，他带着那一丝微笑离开，摄像机拉起，正好捕捉到行人的走动标志，那是电影制作。
And I love the last shot of the limo because him walking away with that little grin on his face and the camera pulling up and just catching the go, the pedestrian go sign is that is movie making.
它告诉你所有需要知道的信息，你能感觉到它在你的胸口。
Like that is like, it tells you everything you need to know and you feel it in your chest.
它不是文字。
It doesn't, uh, it's not words.
我给你写了那封小信，送你在纽约市。
And I wrote you this little day to send you in New York City.
我们马上回来。
We'll be right back.
大家好，我是Hyper-Fixed播客的主持人Alex Goldman。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
每周我们都会解决听众的问题。
Each week we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
问题比如，我30岁了，在纽约开车很害怕。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
或者为什么我在倒车时不能调节汽车音响的音量？
Or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
我们也解决非汽车相关的问题。
We also solve non-car related problems.
如果你有问题，我们不仅会解决它，我们还会揭露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
这就是Radiotopia的HyperFixed播客。
That's the HyperFixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
在任何你获取播客的地方或HyperFixedPod.com找到它。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
现在，回到节目。
And now, back to the show.
还要说一下，我查找了一些关于这一集的有趣事实。
And also, I should say, I found this, I looked up some fun facts about this episode.
我们的摄影师Chris LaFontaine凭借这一集获得了艾美奖摄影奖。
Our cinematographer, Chris LaFontaine, won an Emmy for cinematography for this episode.
这是他的获奖作品。
This was his Emmy winning submission.
当你观看这一集时，它看起来真的很美。
And when you watch this one, it really looks beautiful.
纽约街道外的夜景和我们刚才提到的结局，看起来非常感人。
The night stuff outside of New York Street and the ending we just talked about, it's really quite moving to look at.
这是一个非常精美拍摄的剧集。
It's a beautiful, beautifully shot episode.
拍摄起来也很难，我不觉得人们能理解将摄像机放入豪华轿车并为其打光有多难。
It's also hard, I don't think people understand, it's hard to get cameras into a limo and it's hard to light a limo.
比如，有很多技术挑战。
Like, there were technical challenges.
这真的很困难。
It's really hard.
这一集非常成功，人们并不理解。
That was triumphant in this episode and people don't understand.
我不觉得……真的，我要说这很讽刺，我们应该说，我们已经总结了这一集。
I don't think the- Truly, and I will say the irony, We should say, I mean, we've sort of summarized the episode.
这是我们的除夕大集。
It's our big New Year's Eve episode.
Ted租了一辆豪华轿车，试图从一堆糟糕的除夕夜中夺回一个美好的夜晚。
Ted rents a limo to try to steal back a good New Year's from what is a sea of terrible New Year's Eve.
正如Ted对存衣女孩所说，除夕夜往往很糟糕，好吧，很棒，当它们应该是乐趣所在时，却并非如此。
New Year's Eve's are often terrible, as Ted says to the coat check girl, and okay, awesome, when they're listening stuff, that's supposed to be fun, that is not.
除夕夜，这对Ted说“好吧，我们要拿回除夕夜，今晚我们要让它变得有趣”是一个很好的铺垫。
New Year's Eve, which is a wonderful sort of setup for Ted saying, okay, we're taking back New Year's Eve tonight, we're gonna make this one fun.
他试图为他的朋友们做到这一点，但有Robin在和那个超级富有的人约会的元素，而Ted那晚也有约会。Ted的约会对象离开了，说你爱上了Robin，这是一件在第一季第11集——即第一季的中点——听到的很棒的事情，对于剩下的第一季走向。
And he tries to do that for his group of friends, but there's this element of Robin dating this new guy who's super rich, and Ted has a date that night, and Ted's date sort of goes away, says you're in love with Robin, which is a great thing to hear in episode 11, the dead middle point of season one, for the wear of the rest of season one's going.
她离开了，那么Ted和Robin之间会发生什么吗？
She leaves, and then Ted and Robin is something gonna happen.
不，亿万富翁回来了，找到了Robin。
No, the billionaire guy comes back, finds Robin.
他本不应该在那晚有空，有点阻碍了Ted，但随后Ted和Robin在结尾有了一个美好的时刻，承诺了更多。
He wasn't supposed to be available that night, kind of gets in Ted's way, but then Ted and Robin have this wonderful moment at the end that promises more.
我会说，所有这些总结都是为了说明，我们试图拍一集拍摄起来简单的剧集。
I will say the ones, all of that summary to say, We tried to make an episode that was simple to shoot.
这就是这个想法的来源。
That was how this idea came about.
我们一直在向剧组索求太多。
We had been asking, we've been asking so much of the crew.
我们花费了太多钱。
We had been spending too much money.
我们拍了太多集，以至于我们出色的制作人Susie Greenberg，我们今天早些时候一直在赞美她。
We had been doing so many 60, 70 episodes that our wonderful producer, Susie Greenberg, who's praises, we were just singing earlier today.
Pam Fryman和每个人都让这些集数得以完成。
And Pam Fryman and everybody made these episodes happen.
我们说，这是我们送给你们的礼物。
And we said, here's our gift to you.
我们只在这一辆车里拍。
We're just gonna make an episode mostly in this limo.
大家大部分时间都在一起。
Everybody's together for the most part.
不客气，很简单。
You're welcome, it's so simple.
但拍到最后，每个人都想说，“去你们的”。
And by the end of shooting this episode, everybody was like, fuck you guys.
你们制造的，这是最难拍的一集。
You made, this was the hardest one to shoot.
这真的很难。
It was hard.
这很难。
而且我有一点幽闭恐惧症。
And I run a little claustrophobic.
你知道，这真的很真实，我记得休息时我们有机会走出来，我们就像，哦，你知道，从车里出来。
You know, like it was just, it was a real, I remember on breaks when we would have a moment to step out and we'd be like, oh, you know, coming out of the.
是的，纠正我如果我错了。
Yeah, correct me if I'm wrong.
我们把一辆豪华轿车开进摄影棚，做了他们所说的“穷人的处理”，遮住窗户，大部分在摄影棚里拍摄。
We drove a limo into the sound stage, made it certain poor man's process as they say, right, just black out the windows and shot it on a soundstage mostly.
只有外景是在纽约街头拍的，但我们拍摄的豪华轿车是那辆车吗，还是有一辆特别改装的轿车，座位可以移开，墙壁可以移开？
Only the exterior limo stuff is actually shot on exterior near your street, but the limo that we were shooting in was the same limo question mark, or was it a special limo where it was tricked out to have a different limo where seats lifted out and walls lifted out?
我肯定当时有类似聪明的做法，但该死的，我记不起来了。
I'm sure it was something clever like that, but god damn it, I can't remember.
我不记得了。
I don't remember.
我当时不在片场。
I wasn't on set that way.
我确实记得在22号摄影棚里有一辆真车。
I do have memory of an actual limo being in stage 22.
所以内部的东西都是在棚里那辆车里拍的。
Like we shot.
我不确定，它可能是一辆特别的轿车，东西可以移进移出，而你看到的外部街道上的车并不是那辆，因为它只是一辆普通轿车。
So all the stuff that was inside was shot inside a sound stage in this limo.
但结果证明它极其复杂。
I don't know if it would have, it was probably a special limo where stuff moved in and out and then the limo that actually you see exterior on the street was not that limo because it was just a normal limo that actually drove and didn't have seats lifted.
是的，正如我所说，它成了某种简称，比如，“你宁愿回到轿车里吗？”
But it was incredibly complicated as it turned out.
本来应该是更简单的。
Yeah, like I said, it became a kind of shorthand, like, well, would you rather go back to the limo?
我们被它吓到了，但我的意思是，相比之下，仍然是一份好工作。
It's like, it was supposed to be simpler.
但我认为你在这里注意到了Ted和他的时间表。
We were a little scarred by it, but I mean, scarred relative to, you know, still a good job.
你知道，他需要计划他的……需要有那个“不，不，不，我们要在45分到达，我们要去这个派对”。
But I do think you picked up in here the runner of Ted and his schedule.
但唯一一个他会偏离、即兴创作并进入“让我们看看会发生什么”状态的人是Robin，他会扔掉计划表，如果Robin打来电话，他会吃掉并吞下那份计划表，是的，这在他的约会对象看来很明显。
You know, he's like needing to plan his needing to have the like, no, no, no, we're intended to end 45, we're supposed to be at this party.
是的，那个可怜的约会对象，虽然她对此很甜美，但她说“你爱上了Robin”，在除夕夜的那一刻，在Ted面前听到这句话真的很令人兴奋，因为那正是剩下这一季要讲的故事，当他否认时，她说“你明显爱上了Robin”，他却说“不”，而且他非常真诚。
But the one person he will deviate from and improvise and go into like, well, let's see what happens is Robin, he will throw, he will tear up the schedule, he will he will chew the schedule and swallow it if robin calls yes yeah which his date very much picks up on by the end yeah it's poor date it was the hugger and guess she's very sweet about it but she's like you're in love with robin and it was just really exciting to hear someone say that to Ted's face in that moment on New Year's Eve it was it I loved that moment because it was like well yeah that's what the rest of the season is going to be about and I thought that was uh I thought it was so funny when he denies it she says you clearly in love with robin And he's like, no, and he's very sincere.
她说，而且很明显她也喜欢你。
She says, and it's clear she's, she's into you too.
他却说，等等，真的吗？
And he's like, wait, really?
他演得太棒了。
Like he can't play that so great.
他怎么可能不察觉呢。
He can't not get there.
他太有趣了，他因为其他人敢偏离计划而对他们大喊大叫。
He's so funny and he's yelling at everybody else for daring to deviate from the schedule.
但任何与Robin有关的事，他都会说，“好吧，我们不按剧本来了。”
But anything you're right, anything related to Robin, he's like, all right, we're off book here.
向Kathleen Perkins致敬，她扮演了Mary Beth，那个拥抱的同事，她太棒了。
Just a shout out to Kathleen Perkins, who played Mary Beth the hugger, the hugging coworker, who was so wonderful.
而且，如果你看过其他剧集，她在很多剧中扮演高管。
And also, if you've ever seen the dev show episodes, She was at like a network executive, or like the head of the, yeah.
她在里面表现得令人难以置信地滑稽。
She was so unbelievably funny in that.
我记得几年后看着她演那部剧。
I remember years later just seeing her crush that show.
她太棒了。
She was fantastic.
显然她遇到过一堆高管。
And had clearly encountered a bunch of executives.
她理解了那个精髓，是的。
Like she understood the essence of that, yeah.
但我认为这非常有趣。
But I thought it was really funny.
我想，“哦，她抱了我很多次。”
I was like, well, she hugs me a lot.
也许这意味着她对我有意思。
Maybe that means she's into me.
她只是，她在生理上无法不拥抱别人。
She just, she's constitutionally incapable of not hugging people.
她必须拥抱所有人。
She has to hug everybody.
是的，这是她的特质。
Yeah, it's her thing.
是的，她太棒了。
Yeah, she was great.
我们还应该说JP Manu饰演的“不，Moby”在这一集中非常伟大和标志性。
And we should say JP Manu as not Moby was great and iconic in this episode.
“不，Moby”已经深入文化了，我认为。
Not Moby has stuck in the culture, I think.
嘿，你能讲那个故事吗？
Hey, can you tell the story?
你难道没有一个关于现实交叉的真实故事吗？
Don't you have a real life story about the sort of intersection of reality?
好吧，我认识Moby一点点。
Well, I know Moby a bit.
我是说，如果你在洛杉矶住得足够久，你就会认识Moby。
I mean, if you live in L.A.
他是洛杉矶的Richard Kind。
long enough, you get to know Moby.
他就在那儿。
He's the Richard Kind of L.A.
难道Richard Kind不也是洛杉矶的Richard Kind吗？
He's just, he's around.
但在那之后，我以前常去他住处附近的派对，然后我们俩没过多久就搬到了离他三户人家的地方。所以我，他是我的邻居，我常看见他，遛狗时聊聊天，但我记得在某个时候我说，嘿，人们会告诉你关于这个《老爸老妈罗曼史》剧集吗？
He wasn't Richard Kind also the Richard Kind of L.A.
他说，“是的，一直都有。”
But I ended up I used to go to the East parties when he lived not far from me But then we both moved not long after like three doors down from him So I he was my neighbor I would see him, you know We'd be walking dogs and just have a conversation, but I remember at some point I said hey Do you get do people ever tell you about this how I met your mother episode?
这很有趣，因为当人们遇到他时，我肯定他们会问“你是Moby还是‘不，Moby’？”
And he was like yeah all the time And it's funny because when people run into him, I'm sure they're like are you Moby or not Moby?
但他肯定感觉到了，我不认为这是一种负担，但我认为他感觉到了“是的，我知道这个剧集的存在”。
But he definitely was feeling the I don't think it was a burden, but I think he was feeling like yeah I know this episode is out there.
我不知道他是否看过，但我认为他拼凑出了大概是什么意思，太搞笑了。
I don't know if he'd ever seen it, but I think he had pieced together what what the gist was It's hilarious.
嗯哼。
Mm-hmm.
这是什么意思？
What what does that mean?
为什么人们对我说“不是Moby”这个短语？
Why are people saying the phrase not Moby to me?
你们是怎么想到比如Moby和不是Steven Tyler的？
Where did you come up with like how how Moby and not Steven Tyler?
那是怎么来的？
Like where did that come from?
我认为只是因为我们觉得必须是一个你可能会认错的人。
I think it was just that we thought it had to be a guy that you could you could You could conceivably get it wrong.
你知道我的意思吗？
Do you know what I mean?
比如，Moby，你确实有时会看到长得像Moby的人，对吧？
Like, Moby had, you do sometimes see guys that look like Moby, right?
你的制片人Alec Love就是这样。
You had that just, Alec Love, our producer.
Alec长得像Moby。
Alec looks like Moby.
你也可能看起来像Moby，戴上眼镜，穿着那种嬉皮士跳跃装。
You could look like Moby, you got the glasses on, you got the sort of like hipster track jumpers.
我不是说那是Moby现在的样子，但在90年代末或2000年代初的某个特定时间，有一个非常标志性的Moby造型。
I'm not saying that's what Moby in real life does now, but for a certain time, in the late 90s or early 2000s, there was a very iconic Moby look.
看，Alex在复制，那是眼镜。
There he is, Alex replicating, it was glasses.
我认为这只是，我们当时在推销“谁能让你合理地花时间在轿车里，然后才意识到那不是那个人”，Moby不知何故，这是柏拉图式的理想想法，简直太完美了。你知道我们上一集谈论的菠萝是完美的水果，而Moby是这方面的完美摇滚明星，是的。啊，不，如果你花足够的时间，你必须在编剧室里坐半天，推销各种东西，然后落地到Moby或菠萝，你会想“我不敢相信我生活中在做这个”。我不能为了谈论谁是最好的人而花半天时间，五小时，然后就像Moby。
And I think it was just, we were pitching on, who could you plausibly really get into a memo spend a bunch of time with before realizing it's not that person and it just Moby was somehow it was just the platonic ideal idea just was perfect do you know how it's like we were talking in the last episode like the pineapple was the perfect fruit and Moby was the perfect rock star for this rock star yeah oh no some yeah if you spend enough time and you have to sit around for like half a day in a writer's room just pitching on stuff and to land at Moby or to land at Pine Apple and you go I can't believe this is what I'm doing with my life I can't be paid to do this to talk for half a day about who's the best person and like five hours and it's like Moby.
但之后你会很高兴你花了时间，因为“不是Moby”是——我不认为我们能超越它。
And but then you're glad you spent the time because not Moby was I don't think we could have beaten it.
那太棒了。
That's fantastic.
是的。
Yeah.
这是完美。
It's perfection.
是的。
Yeah.
而且它也……它也让我再次感觉到，就像行动之歌的平衡。
And it also it also like it made me feel again almost like the balance of action song.
它让我觉得我们是在一个当下的剧集里。
It made me feel like we're on a show of the moment.
你知道我的意思吗？
You know what I mean?
就像我们不是在一个谈论Lawrence Welk的剧集里。
Like we're not on a show that's like talking about Lawrence Welk.
就像我们真的在实时发生。
Like we're were like really, were really happening in real time.
而现在它是一部时代剧。
And now it's a period piece.
现在感觉像是，好了，我们回头看。
Like now it feels like, okay, we look back.
那是2005年。
That was 2005.
还有几件事我想要说，这让我感到非常高兴。
There are a couple of things I wanted to, that just delighted me that I just wanted to say.
Barney的CD。
Barney C.D.
太搞笑了。
is hilarious.
而且它应该起伏，不，它应该只是升起又升起。
And the fact that it should rise and fall, but no, it should just rise and rise and rise.
而“不是Moby”同意他的观点。
And that not Moby agrees with him.
哦，当他们连在一起时，“不是Moby”正在说关于音乐的深刻见解。
Oh, when they link up about it and not Moby is saying insightful things about music.
这显然就是Moby，他是个音乐人。
It's like, clearly this is Moby, he's a music guy.
他对音乐一窍不通。
He knows everything about music.
他就像，他是第二，燃烧。
He's like, he's second and burn.
但，我会说很难获得歌曲版权，《你给爱一个坏名声》？
But, yeah, would say it hard to get the rights to, you give love a bad name?
那首歌叫那个吗？
Is that what the song's called?
首先，是的，那是那首歌。
First of all, yeah, that's the song.
你给了一个坏名声。
You give a little bad name.
首先，我觉得这是我们在剧集中播放次数最多的一首歌，因为它开始和停止了大概14次。
First of all, I think it's the most we've ever played a song in an episode, because that song starts and stops like 14 times.
我想你为此付出的代价更高。
I think you have to pay more for that.
我希望这是一个很好的Andy Gamone问题。
I wish this would be a good Andy Gamone question.
如果我们和我们的音乐总监Andy Gamone谈过，我想你可能会给她发短信。
If we ever talked to our music supervisor, Andy Gamone, I think you probably text her.
你会说，我们要放15次。
You're like, we're gonna play it 15 times.
那没问题吗？
Is that okay?
我想可能有加价。
I think there's probably an upcharge there.
但这很贵。
But it was expensive.
这可能是我们迄今为止最昂贵的一首，因为是Bon Jovi。
It was probably our most expensive one today, where it's a Bon Jovi.
这是绝对经典的Bon Jovi歌曲。
It's an absolute classic Bon Jovi song.
我不记得了。
I don't remember.
花了很多钱。
It was a lot of money.
但你想知道关于花半天时间辩论Moby的趣事吗？
But you wanna know something talking about spending half a day debating Moby.
我无法告诉你关于这首歌应该是什么的辩论有多激烈。
I cannot tell you how much of a debate there was about what song this should be.
它必须是一首歌，当你按下播放键时，就完全进入了。
It had to be a song that right when you hit play, it's just all the way in.
完全进入。
It's all the way in.
没有缓慢的构建。
There's no slow build.
没有开场白。
There's no intro piece.
它必须是一首歌，它……
It's right.
Phil Lord和我，这可能是在我们的关系中发生冲突最接近的一次，因为Phil Lord，我所崇拜的，Lord Miller，他们是第一季的编剧，Phil要坚持“Journey的《无论你想要什么》”，那是那首歌的名字吗？
It has to be a song that starts And Phil Lord and I, it's probably the closest we've come to actually having discord in our relationship because Phil Lord, whom I adore, Lord Miller, they were writers on the show on season one, Phil was going to die on the hill of any way you want it by a journey, is that what that song's called?
你知道当你，那首歌进来时，就像“无论你想要什么，是的”。
You know when you, the song comes in, it's like, any way you want, yeah, that's what, yeah.
它进来得太热烈了，就像穿心。
And it comes in so hot, just like shot through the heart.
就像它进来那样。
Like it comes, it's another song that comes in like that.
缩减成那两首歌之间的生死决斗。
got whittled down to this like death match between those two songs.
我们几乎为了那个在大喊大叫，而我处于那个时刻，Bon Jovi，你知道，我当时是个青少年。
And we were almost shouting at each other about like, and I was of the moment, Bon Jovi, you know, I was like a teenager preteen at that moment.
那首歌在那时对我来说比Journey早10、15年更有冲击力。
That song just hit at that point for me much more than journey was, you know, 10, 15 years before that.
所以我认为我可能做了最终决定，那必须是Bon Jovi。
And so I think I think I might have made the final call, like it's got to be, it's got to be done.
我确实记得在网络运行中，我想Dave Bakers每次都按下播放，每次都很好笑，而且越来越好笑，就像Kobe开始唱它时，Robin试图振奋轿车时非常有趣，这也是Andy Galant的好问题，我们应该让Andy Galant来谈谈，我们应该做一集Andy Galant，当Robin开始唱时，那是另外的1.5万吗？我们为此付了多少钱？
I do remember in the network run through, I think Dave Bakers was was just pressing play every time you know off and I do remember it killing like it's funny every time and it gets funnier and it's also like when Kobe starts singing it when Robin's been singing it trying to amp up the car is so funny that would be also a good Andy Galant we should have Andy Galant on to talk about we should do an Andy Galant episode it'd be very funny to say when when Robin starts singing it was that another 15,000 How much did we pay for that?
是的，她只是唱它我们付了多少钱？
Yeah, how much did we pay for her just to sing it?
是的，我认为你必须这样做。
Yeah, I think you have to.
我认为是，是的，我们得问他那个。
I think it's, yeah, we got to ask him that.
我几乎肯定我们也必须为那个付费。
I'm almost positive we would have had to pay for that too.
但这只是，这是完美的歌。
But it's just, it's the perfect song.
它在11点进入。
It comes in on 11.
它只是进来，它在红色中进来。
It just comes in, it comes in in the red.
是的，还有音乐，比如插曲，这是一个行业术语，但它们太重要了。
Yeah, well also there's music, like needle drops, which is an industry term, but they're so important.
太重要了，有时你可以引入一首你喜欢的歌，比如那首Surf，也许很多人没听过。
It's so important, sometimes you can introduce a song like you love, like not a surf, which maybe a lot of people hadn't heard.
这是一首，依赖于它在文化血液中存在20年。
This is one, it's dependent on it being in the cultural bloodstream for 20 years.
你需要一些每个人都熟悉的，这是关于它喜剧的一部分，它就像，它做了它应该做的事，它也做了在不恰当的时刻。
You need something that everyone, that's part of the comedy about it, is it's just like, it just does the thing it's supposed to do, and it also does it at moments that it's inappropriate.
是的。
Yeah.
哦，当有那种尴尬的下拍沉默，然后它又弹出来。
Oh, there's when there's like the awkward sort of downbeat silence and then it pops in again.
这对我看的时候是一个大笑时刻。
That was a laugh out loud moment for me watching it.
而且Barney的整个心理就像CD一旦弄混了，他就变成了Emily Dickinson。
And also that Barney's entire psyche is like as soon as that CD is to get like mixed goes away, he becomes Emily Dickinson.
他没有任何东西，他只是螺旋式陷入黑暗，这几乎就像是他当晚的毒品。
He doesn't have any where he just spirals into darkness, which is almost like it's his drug for the night.
就像这是他保持兴奋的方式。
Like it's his way to stay psyched.
而一旦有了它，他就陷入了存在主义的深坑。
And once he has it, he falls into an existential pit.
那么这是Ranjit自首集以来的第一次重现吗？
So is this the first Ranji reappearance since the pilot?
是的，Ranjit在第一季中出现在两集中，第1集试播集，第11集豪华轿车。
Yes, Ranji appeared in two episodes in season one episode one pilot episode 11 the lima.
好的，就是它。哇，很有趣，有时角色在心理上笼罩着剧集，但就像，是的，我是说，令人惊讶的是他只出现在两集中。他很有存在感。
Okay, there it is Wow, it's so funny how sometimes characters like loom large in the psyche of the show But like yeah, I mean, it's amazing that he was only on two He has so much presence.
他在屏幕上非常在场，而且他也是最善良、最甜美的人，每次我——你从未不喜欢看到Marshall出现在片场。
He's just present on screen and he was also the kindest sweetest human like every time I'm you were never not delighted to see Marshall come on set.
他太美妙了。
He was so wonderful.
我还喜欢“我不希望你看到我生气”。
I also love, I don't want you to see me pissed.
我喜欢那个。
I love that.
我不希望他的生气，Ted。
I don't want his to be pissed, Ted.
太棒了。
It's so great.
他就像，他建立了友谊。
He's like, he struck up a friendship.
你知道我的意思吗？
You know what I mean?
他是个绅士。
He's a gentleman.
是的，是的。
Yeah, yeah.
Ranjit是为豪华轿车公司开车，然后Ted找到了他吗？
Was Ranjit driving for the limo company and Ted found him?
Ted租了一辆车并雇佣Ranjit当司机吗？
Did Ted rent a limo and hire Ranjit to be the driver?
这是怎么运作的？
Like, how does this work?
而且Ted是怎么追踪到他的？
And how did Ted track him down?
我们只是假设在那个香槟之夜结束时，他们说，“让我们保持联系。”
Do we just assume at the end of that champagne night, they were like, let's all stay in touch.
是的，让我们保持联系。
Yeah, let's all stay in touch.
他们可能说“让我们买个酒吧”之类的时刻。
They probably let's let's all buy a bar type of moment.
我想，是的，强烈暗示Ranjit现在也为豪华轿车公司开车，因为他说“我在提升自己”。
I think, yeah, it's definitely strongly implied that Ranchi now drives for the limo company too, because he says, I'm moving up in the world.
他从出租车升到为特殊活动驾驶一辆旧大轿车。
He's moving up from cab to driving a big old limo for special events.
还有几件事。
A couple other things.
这是我第一次听到这个短语，我很喜欢，当Lily说“这些狗在叫”时，那是Courtney Kain的台词吗？
This is the first time I ever heard the phrase, and I love it, but when Lily said these dogs are barking, was that a Courtney Kain line?
我觉得那可能是Courtney Kain的台词。
I feel like that might have been a Courtney Kain line.
这是一个古老的短语，短语本身就存在。
That is an old, that phrase pre-exists.
那是我的新英雄。
That is my new hero.
不，我知道它存在。
No, I know it existed.
但我从未听说过它。
But I've never heard it before.
是的，是的，是的。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是Courtney推销的吗？
Was did Courtney pitch it?
我能看出Courtney在推销那个。
I can see Courtney pitching that.
天哪，我不记得了。
God, I can't remember.
我爱这些狗。
I love these dogs.
我喜欢Lily只是说奇怪的东西，比如“这些狗在叫”。
I love when Lily would just say weird shit, like these dogs are barking.
这些狗在叫，是的。
These dogs are barking, yeah.
太搞笑了。
It's so funny.
是的，是的。
Yeah, yeah.
Natalia很棒。
Natalia is great.
那个醉酒的。
The drunk.
非常有趣。
Very funny.
我超级爱你。
I super love you.
她，我的意思是，有时客串明星。
She was, she, I mean, sometimes guest stars.
实际上在剧集中客串是非常难的，因为我们这五个人，我们住在那里，对吧？
It's actually very hard to guest star on a show Because we, the five of us, we live there, right?
他们进入我们的房子。
They're coming into our house.
我们认识整个剧组，当你作为系列常客时感受到的温暖和轻松自在，与客串明星感受到的完全不同。
We know the whole crew, it's the warmth that you feel and the ease and comfort you feel when you're a series regular is so different than what a guest art feels.
他们很快就被选角。
They get cast very quickly.
他们去服装试穿。
They go into a wardrobe fitting.
他们接着是那个。
They're on to that.
也许那天下午或第二天或两天后，也许他们甚至没有在。
Maybe the next, that afternoon or the next day or two days later, maybe they haven't even been, I don't remember.
我不认为她在运行中。
I don't think she was at the run-through.
我想她后来被选角了。
I think she got cast later.
所以我总是很惊讶当演员能作为客串明星进来并把它搞定。
So I'm always amazed when actors can come on and just crush it as a guest star.
因为你真的是进来了。
Because you're really coming in.
我记得有人说，“这就是在法律与秩序中客串的感觉，就像，我在卸货。”
I remember someone said, here's what guest starring in law and order is like, it's like, I'm unloading groceries.
我妻子死了？
My wife is dead?
就像你必须从这种疯狂的、平凡的任务转变为最感人的任务。
Like you just have to pivot from this insane, like, banal task to the most emotional thing.
而系列常客就像，“没错，你妻子死了。”
And the series regulars are just like, that's right, your wife is dead.
他们可以保持冷静。
Like they get to be stoic.
而且……冷静，对吧？
and kind of, you know, chill, right?
是的，飞进来做那个真的很难。
Yeah, it's really hard to fly in and do that.
而且这一集非常适合那样，对吧？
And this was a great episode for that, right?
那些，这一集里的每个人都很棒。
Those, everybody in this episode was great.
而且它需要是那样，因为每个人都被困在一辆该死的豪华轿车里。
And then it needed to be, because everyone's stuck in a fucking limo.
我喜欢这是一个关于除夕派对的剧集，而你甚至看不到一个除夕派对的一秒钟。
I love that it's an episode about New Year's Eve parties, and you don't see one second of a single New Year's Eve party.
它非常像《罗森克兰茨和吉尔登斯特恩死了》，比如哈姆雷特的故事在别处发生。
It's very like Rose and Krantz and Guildenstern are dead, like the Hamlet stories happening somewhere else.
是的，是的，是的，是的。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
好吧，还有，你知道，关于除夕夜很悲惨的事，就像，这是另一件事，虚构世界中实际发生的事情与我们世界中发生的事情相呼应。
Well, also, you know, the thing about New Year's Eve being miserable, like, this is another thing where the what was actually happening in the fictional world was mirroring what was happening in our world.
就像我们在那辆车里并不快乐，就像它开始感觉极其幽闭。
Like we weren't happy in that limo, like it started to feel incredibly claustrophobic.
你需要出去伸展腿，它只是……就像一种压力。
You needed to get out and stretch your legs and it was just it was just it was just like a pressure.
里面一定也很热。
It must have been hot in there too.
它在你的脸上闪电，也许……我不知道是不是因为这个，因为我有一个叮当声。
It was lightning in your face and your maybe and I wonder if that's why because I did one okay I have one ding.
我现在看剧集时喜欢给它们写笔记，没有人穿得够暖和迎接纽约的除夕。
I like to give notes on the episodes when I watch them now and no one was dressed warmly enough for New Year's Eve in New York.
这感觉有点洛杉矶，有点洛杉矶，对吧？
It felt a little LA, it felt a little LA, right?
没有大件厚外套的证据，然后甚至他们穿的，也许外套都在轿车的某个角落里，但甚至他们穿的，比如Robin穿的是这个，无袖，就像整个过程，就像他们会冷得要死。
There was an evidence of big bulky jackets, and then like even what they were wearing, maybe the jackets were all in a corner somewhere of the limo in a pile maybe, but even what they're wearing like Robins in this like sleeveless, like it's like the whole time, like they would be so fucking freezing.
但我认为一部分是那辆车里有多热，而服装师就像，如果我们把他们都穿上毛衣等，他们会在里面流汗。
But I thought part of it is how hot it was in that limo, and wardrobe is like, they're gonna be sweating balls in there if we put them all in sweaters and shit.
我几乎确定我们进行了那种谈话，而且我几乎确定这是一个考虑因素。
I'm almost sure we had that conversation, and I'm almost sure that was a consideration.
比如我们，而且你不想有笨重的夹克你在进出车子。
Like we, and you don't want to have bulky jackets that you're carrying in and out of the car.
我想我们只是做了一个游戏时间的决定，比如我们不会……而且行星，是的，没有现在那么暖和。
I think we just made a game time decision, like we're not gonna, and also the planet, yeah, wasn't as warm as it is now.
所以。
So.
那会很冷的。
It would have been cold.
我看着她的回归，她就像，“不，我大叫胡扯。”
I was watching her throw back on and she was like, no, I call bullshit.
他们会再次被我们更加咕哝。
They would be much more mumbled after us again.
你知道是什么让我发笑，这是某件事，我记不清谁是这个的大冠军。
Do you know what made me laugh, which was something that, I can't remember who was the big champion of this.
我想Jason参与了这个，但我们整个九年都有这个。
I think Jason was in on this, but we had this the whole nine years.
但当车停下来时，我们会像那样。
but when the car stops, we would go like that.
是的，是的，是的。
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
我注意到有一个我有点错过了。
And I noticed there was one that I kind of missed.
就像我，“哦，是的，我们本应该……”，但每个人真的都在做。
Like I was like, oh yeah, we're supposed to, but everyone was really into doing it.
但我总觉得它很傻，因为你没有走那么快。
But I always thought it was silly because you're not going that fast.
这是纽约市，对吧？
It's New York City, right?
就像你以15英里的速度行驶，然后你停下来。
Like you're going 15 miles an hour and you stop.
你不烧保险杠司机。
You don't burn a bumper driver.
但每个人真的都在做。
But everyone was really into doing it.
它只是……就像这个有趣的小笑话，在剧集中并不那么好笑。
And it was just like this funny little joke that is not that funny in the episode.
它只是，它在片场很有趣。
It's just, it was funny on set.
你知道，它几乎得到了将军……它正在试图得到将军。
You know, it's almost getting like getting the general It's trying to get the general.
是的，这真的很对。
Yeah, it's really right.
是的，那真的很滑稽，我喜欢那些可能成为九年运行的东西，只是在你们演员自己的脑海中。
Yeah, that's really funny I love those things that could become runners over nine years just just in your own mind as actors like you You guys are working in guys guys guys a lot for a while because Michael Shai always used to say guys guys guys You're like if there's just the word guys in the script you would always change it to guys guys guys guys To our AD Michael yeah, this is a sentence that I don't think had ever been uttered on on national television before, but I think we were the first to say, hell of a woman, let's go get some hot dogs.
你们家伙伙伙伙在剧本中，如果那里只有一个家伙字，你们总是会把它改成家伙伙伙伙给我们的AD Michael，是的，这是一个我觉得在全国电视上从未被说过的句子，但我认为我们是第一个说“地狱般的女人，我们去拿些热狗”。
Right?
对吧？
It's such a weird turn.
这是一种奇怪的转折。
Hell of a woman.
地狱般的女人。
He says it's very cold hell of a woman.
他说这非常冷地狱般的女人。
You know, in some ways, Marshall's entire personalities encapsulated in that whole line.
你知道，在某些方面，Marshall的整个性格概括在那整行台词中。
So he's got like his romantic kind of like, I love this woman and I'm gonna always be here for her.
所以他有他的浪漫，比如“我爱这个女人，我将永远为她在这里”。
And also, god damn it, let's get those hot dogs.
而且，“该死的，让我们去拿那些热狗”。
I love after that moment, the cut to the next scene is him saying, wow, we're riding around in a limo eating hot dogs.
我喜欢在那一刻之后，剪辑到下一场景是他说的，“哇，我们坐在豪华轿车里吃热狗”。
It's like we're the president.
就像我们是总统。
We're the president.
我们是总统。
But you know what the president does.
但你知道总统做什么。
That's now what our president does.
那是现在我们总统做什么。
That is a 100 percent now, you know, but back then it was kind of absurd.
那是100%现在，你知道，但在那时它是荒谬的。
But now literally like our president is in limos with Big Macs.
但现在实际上比如我们的总统在轿车里配大麦克。
He's 100 percent doing that as we speak.
他100%在我们说话时在做那个。
old man.
老人。
He musted me fell in love with you.
他一定爱上了你。
New York City.
纽约市。
And now commercials, end of commercials back to show.
现在广告，广告结束回到节目。
Okay, this is where I got to call out a, uh, this is where I got to call out a, uh, a dated thing.
好的，这就是我要呼叫一个……这是我要呼叫一个……一个过时的东西。
And it made me laugh every time.
而且它每次都让我笑。
Yeah.
是的。
I can't get through the circuits are jam.
我无法通过电路是堵塞的。
What the fuck was happening?
到底发生了什么？
We said that so many times.
我们说了那么多遍。
So many times.
那么多遍。
You picture like the the old time the operator like trying to plug in the things and get the calls through.
你想象那种老式操作员……试图插入东西并接通电话。
I was like, are we radar from mash?
我是，“我们是Mash里的雷达吗？”
What's happening?
发生了什么？
Are they trilikes?
它们是三条线吗？
We're trying to get to Turkey on the line and see if they've got some extra you know what this exchange maybe laughs because Marshall goes, I can't get through the circuits Mr. jammed and you made me say well that's New Year's Eve for you what the fuck was that a note or did we do did where we asked to do I got I dabbed in my skin crawl so much I'm like is it 1874 like what's happening right now uh Tony Express I can't get through the Lily Lily it's Marshall stop and then at the end there's a nice daguerreotype photograph whoosh with the big like yeah that's it's everything about those moments we're so I was sitting there going why did we act like it was I didn't I can't expect it that's it feels like it was a note that we got enough people enough wimium listeners want this I think a funny t-shirt would be I can't get through the circuits or jam circuits or jam it's like three times we've had that phrase I think it's four.
我们试图在热线上联系土耳其看他们是否有额外的你知道这次交换也许让我发笑因为Marshall说“我无法通过电路被堵塞了”，而你让我说“那是除夕夜为你准备的”，到底是什么，那是一个注释还是我们做了……我们被要求做……我皮肤发痒，太多了，我是1874年吗，现在发生了什么……Tony Express我无法通过Lily Lily是Marshall停止，然后在最后有一个好的达盖尔摄影照片，有那种……是的，那是……关于那些时刻的一切我们是如此……我坐在那里想为什么我们表现得好像它是……我没有……我无法期待那是……感觉它是一个注释，我们得到足够的人足够……听众想要这个，我认为一个有趣的T恤应该是“我无法通过电路或堵塞电路或堵塞”，我觉得三次我们有那个短语，我觉得是四次。
I think it's four.
我觉得是四次。
That's four.
那就是四次。
I mean, it really is a runner in the thing.
我的意思是，它真的是里面的一个运行者。
And it really, it makes us look like we were, yeah, like, mash.
而且它真的……它让我们看起来像是，是的，就像Mash。
Like it makes you look.
就像它让你看起来。
It's a hundred years ago.
这是一百年前的事了。
And it's like, were we so concerned that people would be like, ah, why can't they get some in a cell phone?
而且就像，“我们是否如此担心人们会像，啊，为什么他们不能在手机上得到一些？”
Sometimes you don't hear your ringer.
有时你听不到你的铃声。
The call didn't go through.
电话没打通。
That happens now in 2025.
这发生在现在的2025年。
There was no need to explain that at any moment.
没必要在任何时候解释那个。
And we were like, really over explaining that one.
而且我们就像，真的过度解释了那一个。
Oh my God.
哦，我的天哪。
Oh, God.
哦，上帝。
Sorry.
对不起。
Sorry, everyone.
对不起，大家。
That was a mess on our part.
那是我们这边的混乱。
Can I ask if there was mix of broken logic with Marshall's phone?
我可以问Marshall的手机是否有破损逻辑的混合吗？
Yeah, I think there was, because I think she did.
是的，我想有，因为我想她做到了。
I think one of those, like, the circuits are, like, I think one of those, his phone was still stuck in the limo, right?
我想那些之一，比如，电路是……比如，我想其中一个，他的手机还卡在轿车里，对吧？
And she's, and she's still saying that stupid line when that, we didn't have to say it there.
而她……而她还在说那句愚蠢的台词，当那……我们不必在那里说它。
Because anyway, I'm sorry, everyone.
因为不管怎样，对不起，大家。
No, no.
不，不。
I mean, these are the kind of funny things that it's almost like, you know, like famous when props get misplaced, shot to shot, like famous.
我的意思是，这些是那种有趣的东西，它几乎就像，你知道，比如当道具被放错位时，镜头到镜头，比如著名的。
in great movies, right?
在伟大的电影里，对吧？
Oh, yeah, it happens in everything.
哦，是的，它发生在一切里。
It happens in everything you can't avoid it.
它发生在一切里，你无法避免它。
I think in this one too, I think Mo, not Moby, leaves with the disc, believes with like the case of the get-ciked mix, not just the CD itself, but then all of a sudden it's back in the limo.
我想在这个里也是，我想Mo，“不是Moby”，带着光盘离开，带着比如得到ciked混音的箱子，不仅是CD本身，但突然间它又回到了轿车里。
Empty has pretty city-staking the disc.
空有漂亮城市的CD。
I think that was a glitch.
我想那是一个故障。
I think I remember getting called out on that and being like, yeah, that feels like weird.
我想我记得在那个上被叫出来，就像，是的，那感觉很奇怪。
You know, when I was editing one of my movies, I worked with this great editor both times, Michael Miller, and he had edited Raising Arizona and Ghost World and all these really incredible, yeah.
你知道，当我编辑我的一部电影时，我两次与这位伟大的编辑Michael Miller工作，他编辑了《抚养亚利桑那》和《幽灵世界》和所有这些真正令人难以置信的，是的。
Talk about editing.
谈论编辑。
Yeah.
是的。
And he did a couple of Conrad, but he was a great editor.
而且他做了几个Conrad，但他是一个伟大的编辑。
I learned a lot from him.
我从他那里学到了很多。
And we had lost a scene, we had edited out a scene, and then it made it look like they changed clothes in the middle of the day.
而且我们丢失了一个场景，我们编辑掉了一个场景，然后它看起来像他们中途换了衣服。
And he said to me, I'll never forget this, he said, audiences don't pay attention to that.
而且他对我说了，我永远不会忘记这个，他说，“观众不注意那个。”
And do you know the Robert Redford movie, Three Days in the Condor?
而且你知道Robert Redford的电影《秃鹰三天》吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Originally, the original script was called Six Days in the Condor.
最初，最初的剧本叫《秃鹰六天》。
And in editing, they were like, we need to compress the time.
而且在编辑中，他们就像，“我们需要压缩时间。”
It works better as three days.
作为三天工作得更好。
And if you watch the movie in the middle of the day, they just switch.
而且如果你在一天中间看电影，他们只是切换。
They're just changing clothes.
他们只是换衣服。
And he said, no one has ever brought it up in movie history.
而且他说，电影史上从没有人提到过。
Like no one says anything about it, which I think is an incredible thing.
就像没人说关于它的任何事，我认为这是一个令人难以置信的事。
Like, what are we, what are we watching and what are we paying attention to?
比如，我们是什么……我们正在看什么，我们正在注意什么？
You know, but I think I think some of these things like I think there's a timeless aspect to how I made your mother That is why it's so widely beloved because teenagers right now are watching it and it feels relevant to them They can relate to it's not too.
你知道，但我认为我……我认为一些这些东西，比如我想有一个永恒的方面关于我如何制作你的母亲，这就是为什么它如此广泛地被喜爱，因为现在的青少年正在看它，它对他们感觉相关，他们可以联系，它不是太……它没有那么远，就像……它被过去吞噬了，但有这些标记它是在2005年，而且我认为它们是甜美和酷的，而不是实际上要道歉的。不，不。
It's not so far like It's been swallowed by the past But there are these markers that it was 2005 and I think that they're sweet and cool and not to be apologized for actually No, no.
它捕捉到了它。
It captures it.
而且看，这是一个从2030年讲述2005年的故事。
And look, it's a story being told from 2030 about 2005.
而且在2030年，你会回头看它，说我们在现在所说的。
And in 2030, you'd be looking back at it saying what we're saying right now.
我们现在是在2025年。
We're in 2025 right now.
是的，你几乎像创造了一个环境，你可以逃脱所有这一切。
Yeah, you almost like created a context where you get away with all that.
说年份没关系。
It's okay to say the year.
没关系，因为它是一个关于那一年的故事。
It's okay because it's a story about that year.
奇怪的将是当现实世界超过2030年时，如果我们都能活那么久。
What will be weird is when the real world passes 2030 if we all survive that long.
谁知道呢？
Who knows?
TBD。
TBD.
而且那将像是，哦该死的，那在增加另一层奇怪。
And that is going to be like, oh shit, that's adding another level of weirdness.
但在那一刻，它仍然……是的，那在Ted Mosby的生活的那一年发生没关系。
But at the moment, it's still, Yeah, it's okay this that happened in that year of Ted Mosby's life.
是的，未来的Ted会谈论它……是的，他不会在故事里升级任何人的手机。
Yeah, future Ted gets to talk about it Yeah, he's not gonna upgrade anyone's phones in the story.
是的，虽然我不觉得有人在说短语“电路繁忙”，即使在二……我不记得曾经说过那个。
Yeah Although I don't think anyone was saying the phrase the circuits are busy even in two that I don't remember ever saying that Well, that's New Year's Eve for you That line jumped out at me to Josh and I was like poor Josh having to say that line Well, you'll notice that I really try to make sure work of it.
好吧，那是除夕夜为你们准备的，那句台词对我来说跳出来了，Josh，我当时想，可怜的Josh不得不说那句台词。
I was like well, that's what you do when you get a real clunker Yeah, you just try to act like it's you just throw it away, you know, I'm gonna look for more of those as we continue the rewatch I think if it was like the third or fourth season, I would have gone up to you and said I'm not saying this line You should have you and you damn well should have I know I was still trying to be a good student, you know I'm still trying to get the a I Why I thought you sit when mo when not Moby says I thought you said Tony and And then he says, so your name is Tony and he says, no, no, it's so funny.
好吧，你会注意到我真的试图确保它的工作。
He is so crazy and and we and he's wonderful that in that episode.
我当时想，好吧，那就是当你得到一个真正的笨蛋时你所做的事情。
And then what I love about that moment is you figure, well, that's it.
是的，你只是试图表现得好像它是……你只是把它扔掉，你知道，我会寻找更多那些，当我们继续重温时。
We're never going to hear know this guy's name.
我想如果它是像第三或第四季，我会走到你那里说“我没说这句台词”。
And then there's that wonderful way later in the episode, Marshall says Moby signs my shirt.
你应该有的，而且你该死的应该有，我知道我还在试图做一个好学生，你知道，我还在试图得到a。
He tries to run it says Eric on the top of the shirt.
为什么我想当你……当“不是Moby”说，“我以为你说Tony”，然后他说，“所以你的名字是Tony”，然后他说，“不，不，太搞笑了”。
We did get to solve that mystery is the guy's name is Eric, which as you put it out Josh sounds not at all like Tony or Moby or Moby and also like just Eric it's just like really crudely drawn like it's not like a signature it's just like the guy's a proper psycho.
他是如此疯狂，而且我们……而且他很美妙，在那个剧集中。
He's a psycho he's waving that gun around he did JP Manuke captured that unhinged energy very well.
然后我喜欢那个时刻的是你弄清楚，好吧，那就是它了。
Speaking of waving the gun around I did catch something I did that I thought was delightful.
我们永远不会听到这个家伙的名字。
When he's waving the gun around I hold the party schedule note card up to my head to protect me from an errant bullet.
然后有那个美妙的方式在剧集后面，Marshall说“Moby在我的衬衫上签名”。
If you look, I'm holding it up like, oh, God.
他试图运行它，它在衬衫顶部写着Eric。
There's a metaphor there, because Ted thinks plans will save him.
我们确实得到了解决那个谜团，那个家伙的名字叫Eric，正如你所指出的Josh，听起来一点也不像Tony或Moby或Moby，而且也只是Eric，它只是……真正粗糙地画出来，就像它不是一个签名，它只是……那个家伙是一个真正的精神病。
Plans will save everything.
他是一个精神病，他挥舞着那把枪，他JP Manuke捕捉到了那种不安的能量，非常好。
Exactly.
说到挥舞枪，我确实捕捉到了一些我……我原以为是令人愉快的。
当他挥舞枪时，我把派对计划卡举到我的头上以保护我免受迷途子弹的伤害。
Oh, my God.
如果你看，我举着它像，“哦，上帝”。
So, yeah, I think it's the most we've ever played one song in the Bunch of the Song.
那里有一个隐喻，因为Ted认为计划会拯救他。
I know there's probably no other episode where a song starts and stops a dozen times.
计划会拯救一切。
And very, I will call one other cool song out there.
完全正确。
the song major leagues by pavement plays for also in a major leagues, or maybe it's just major league singular, a great song from Terry Twilight by pavement that is about being ready for great things.
It is a great like love song that sort of talks about I'm going to screw up and I'm ready like bring on the major leagues, like bring on a real love now.
哦，我的天哪。
And that's near the end, near the end that great ending where Ted walks off kind of into the future.
所以，是的，我认为这是我们玩过最多的歌，在一堆歌里。
But it's sort of great because you think that's the ending song, but then it gets cut off by Robin's billionaire, hundred-millionaire boyfriend showing up and he kind of cuts off that song.
我知道可能没有其他剧集，其中一首歌开始和停止了十几次。
I like the kind of fake out where you think that song is kind of going to carry you through to the happy ending.
而且非常……我会叫出那里的一首其他酷歌。
And it doesn't.
歌曲“职业联赛”由Pavement演奏，也为“职业联赛”，或者也许只是职业联赛单数，来自Terry Twilight由Pavement的一首伟大的歌，是关于为伟大的事情做好准备的。
It gets cut off and Ted has a bit of very bittersweet in years Eve with this little moment of hope from Robin.
这是一首伟大的……情歌，谈论“我将搞砸，而且我准备好了……就像把职业联赛带来，就像现在带来真正的爱”。
But that was a little fake out ending song of pavement that didn't actually be the ending song.
而且那是在最后，在最后那个伟大的结尾，Ted走开了，有点进入未来。
I like that.
但这有点伟大，因为你认为那是结尾曲，但随后它被Robin的亿万富翁，亿万富翁男友出现而切断，而他有点切断了那首歌。
I did.
我喜欢那种伪造的结局，你认为那首歌有点会带你完成快乐的结局。
We talked about this, but I love the sunroof being this other playing space and I just There was something so pleasurable.
而且它没有。
Maybe it was just, I got to leave the limo, but there was something so nice about popping up and having a scene up there.
它被切断了，而Ted有了一点点非常苦乐参半的除夕夜，有着Robin的一点希望。
And also we had talked about this when Mary Beth says she can tell Robins into him and he says, wait, really?
但那是Pavement的一点伪造的结局曲，它实际上并没有成为结局曲。
And it occurred to me, like, Ted is a bad actor.
我喜欢那个。
Like I hope I'm a good actor, but Ted is a bad actor.
是的。
It's true.
我们谈论了这个，但我喜欢天窗作为这个其他表演空间，而且我只是……有一些东西非常令人愉快。
He's not a master of disguise.
也许只是，我不得不离开轿车，但有一些非常好的东西关于探出头并在那里有一个场景。
Like Barney's a pretty good actor, and most of his life is somewhat of an act or a lot of it.
而且我们谈论过这个，当Mary Beth说她能看出Robins对我有意思时，他却说，“等等，真的吗？”
Yes.
而且它发生在我身上，比如，Ted是一个坏演员。
But Ted is just, he's a guile-less, is that the word?
就像我希望我是一个好演员，但Ted是一个坏演员。
Like he's...
这是真的。
He's guile-less.
他不是一个伪装大师。
Yeah.
就像Barney是一个相当好的演员，而且他的大部分生活有点像一个行为或很多它。
是的。
There's no, there's no smoke screen.
但Ted只是，他是一个……无诈的，是那个词吗？
There's nothing, he's not masking.
就像他……
He can't help himself but ask his date if she really thinks Robin likes him.
他是无诈的。
It's that there's something so, it's sort of shitty and great at the same time because Ted just can't lie.
是的。
He can't cover that up.
Yeah.
没有什么，没有什么烟雾弹。
没有什么，他没有遮掩。
that moment.
他禁不住问他的约会对象是否真的认为Robin喜欢他。
Great.
那是有一些非常……它有点糟糕且伟大的同时，因为Ted只是不能撒谎。
Speaking of smoke screens, I love Marshall emerging from that steam.
他不能覆盖那个。
Oh my God.
是的。
Lily, I'm going to go call Marshall and she just means calling his name out.
That was I love when we have those little magic New York moments and that entire city he can she can call his name echoing through the buildings through the canyons of New York and he will come running out of the smoke that I love the metaphysical weirdness of New York is a very strange place.
那个时刻。
It's this intensely small village and it's one of the biggest cities in the world.
伟大。
all at the same time.
说到烟雾弹，我喜欢Marshall从那蒸汽中涌现。
Oh, at the same time.
哦，我的天哪。
Yeah.
Lily，“我将去叫Marshall”，而她只是意味着叫出他的名字。
And there's something like, if you really understand New York and the geography of at least Manhattan, that's impossible.
那是……我喜欢当我们要那些小魔法纽约时刻，而且那整个城市，她可以……她可以叫他的名字在建筑物中回荡，通过纽约的峡谷，而他会从我爱的烟雾中跑出来，那是纽约的形而上学奇怪，这是一个非常奇怪的地方。
It's impossible.
这是一个极其小的村庄，而且它是世界上最大的城市之一。
It's like, it's too loud.
所有在同一时间。
It's too crazy.
哦，在同一时间。
Like, even if he was half a block away, you can't hear someone screaming a flag away.
是的。
I knew you.
而且有东西像是，如果你真的理解纽约和曼哈顿至少的地理，那是不可能的。
是不可能的。
I knew you.
它像是，它太吵了。
In New York City.
它太疯狂了。
Yeah.
就像，即使他半个街区远，你也不能听到某人尖叫一街之隔。
But it's magic.
我认识你。
Like, Alec and I talk about this, like, like, just adding magic into scripts.
Like Alec, I've been to tell something you told me about Fargo speaking of the Coen brothers.
我认识你。
You said a female police chief investigating a murder in, where was it, Minnesota, is great, but that she's pregnant is magic, right?
在纽约市。
Right.
是的。
Yeah.
但这是魔法。
就像，Alec和我谈论这个，就像……就像，只是增加魔法到剧本中。
Yeah.
就像Alec，我必须告诉某事你告诉我的关于Fargo说到Coen兄弟。
你说一个女性警察局长调查谋杀案，在……哪里是，Minnesota，是伟大的，但她是怀孕的是魔法，对吧？
Yeah.
正确。
是的。
Yeah.
loving emerging from.
是的。
I mean, it's almost like a professional wrestler coming out of the dressing room, like in the fog.
Like he, there was something he, you could tell he was in the same way, like, okay, awesome.
爱的从……涌现。
He loved the dance.
我的意思是，它几乎像一个专业摔跤手从更衣室出来，比如在雾中。
Like, he loved coming out of that.
就像他，那里有东西，你可以看出他在同样的方式，比如，好的， awesome。
Yeah.
他喜欢舞蹈。
Now he runs, he appears out of the smoke.
就像，他喜欢从那个出来。
The Bon Jovi song for the first time becomes full score.
是的。
It's not being played in the limo.
现在他跑了，他从烟雾中出现。
It's actually the score and it plays him in.
Bon Jovi歌第一次成为完整分数。
And it is a very get psyched moment.
它没有在轿车里被播放。
And Jason leaned into it.
它实际上是分数，而且它让他进入。
I love, I love that moment so much.
而且这是一个非常“得到兴奋”的时刻。
And there's a third is magic like the fact that not Moby is at the same party.
而且Jason倾向于它。
They were gonna go to right the billion the mill hundred Millionaire finding Robin at all marshals names somehow magically calling him out of the mist His wife calling his name sort of makes him appear I feel like he was way far away from them and a portal appeared And you ran through the portal towards Lily's voice and he jumped down three floors Yeah, he jumped three floors, but Lily's voice made it all possible.
我喜欢，我喜欢那个时刻非常多。
He loves her so much.
而且有第三个是魔法，比如“不是Moby”在同一个派对的事实。
I love that moment so much much.
他们将要去，对，亿万富翁，百万富翁找到Robin，完全Marshalls名字不知何故神奇地从雾中叫他出来，他的妻子叫他的名字使他出现，我觉得他离他们很远，而一个门户出现了，而你穿过门户向Lily的声音，而且他跳了三层楼，是的，他跳了三层楼，但Lily的声音使一切可能。
What's wonderful about this shows use of that kind of magic is that it's almost leaning on the fact that you have purchased a kind of trust from your audience to then allow to break all the rules that you have.
他爱她那么多。
Because certainly if you mess up continuity somewhere and you're wearing the wrong clothing, you're wearing the wrong guy, that's like a ding for an audience.
我爱那个时刻非常多，很多。
They'll sort of notice that if all of a sudden you just break reality and just say is that what you're saying is, do you want to have fun or not?
关于这个节目使用那种魔法的精彩之处在于，它几乎依赖于你已经购买了一种对你的观众的信任，从而允许打破你拥有的所有规则。
Right.
因为当然如果你搞砸了连续性在某处，而且你穿了错误的衣服，你穿了错误的家伙，那就像是一个观众的ding。
And I think that once you've got them, they love these people and they know what the show is.
他们会有点注意到那个，如果突然你只是打破现实并只是说，“你想要玩得开心还是不玩？”
Oh, it's not a show that's supernatural.
正确。
This is a real life show, I'm in.
而且我认为一旦你拥有了他们，他们爱这些人，而且他们知道节目是什么。
But now you're asking, hey, do you want to something crazy with me?
哦，它不是一个超自然的节目。
Come jump out a window with me and land three floors down and you had them at that point.
这是一个真实的生活节目，我是在。
And so you could introduce this kind of thing.
但现在你正在问，“嘿，你想做点疯狂的事和我一起吗？”
trust the audience to make these magical realism-based leaps, except in the case of not being able to complete a cell phone call, in which case we have to say the circuit service.
跟我跳出窗户，跳三层楼下，而且你在那一刻拥有了他们。
That one we had to explain.
所以你可以引入这种东西。
Marshall appearing out of the smoke, that's fine.
信任观众来做这些魔法现实主义基础的跳跃，除了不能完成手机通话的情况，在这种情况下我们必须说电路……。
Well, how we may, because it's this memory play, you're allowed to bend time and space and defy the laws of physics in a different way.
那个我们必须解释。
What a trick.
Marshall从烟雾中出现，那很好。
What a magic trick to get to use, is the trick of the unreliable narrator, the unreliability of memory itself.
嗯，如何我们可以，因为它是这个记忆剧，你被允许弯曲时间和空间，而且 defy 物理定律以不同的方式。
This is another magic moment, is that Marshall steals back the CD from Not Moby.
这是一个什么技巧。
Like one, how would he know?
什么魔法技巧去得到使用，是不可靠叙述者的技巧，记忆本身的不可靠。
Like the amount of leaps that Marshall would have to make to figure out that this is Barney CD, Not Moby stole it.
这是另一个魔法时刻，是Marshall从“不是Moby”那里偷回CD。
How did you see that?
比如一，他怎么会知道？
But he thinks he's still Moby.
就像Marshall必须做出的飞跃去弄清楚这是Barney的CD，“不是Moby”偷了它。
He's still thinks he's Moby.
你怎么会看到那个？
But he steals it back.
但他认为他仍然是Moby。
And it made me feel, because we get it, I don't remember when telepathy appeared, but it's one of my favorite how I made your mother jokes, is that they could speak telepathically to each other?
他仍然认为他是Moby。
Yes, they speak telepathically.
但他把它偷回来。
But it made me realize that like, they actually already have telepathy.
而且它让我感觉，因为我们得到了它，我不记得当心灵感应出现时，但它是我的最爱如何制作你的母亲笑话之一，是他们可以心灵感应地对彼此说话？
Yes.
是的，他们心灵感应地说话。
Like they know what they need, they anticipate each other's needs, they can spit, they're sensing something about each other.
但它让我意识到，就像，他们实际上已经有心灵感应。
They're an ecosystem or a biosphere, you know?
是的。
It's even better that he thought it was really Moby.
就像他们知道他们需要什么，他们预测彼此的需要，他们可以吐，他们正在感应关于彼此的东西。
He's like, I'm stealing that thing back from Moby.
他们是一个生态系统或生物圈，你知道吗？
Moby cannot steal.
甚至更好，他认为它是真正的Moby。
Moby may think he's a big, famous star, but he cannot steal my friends and get psychics.
他就像，“我正在从Moby那里偷回那个东西。”
And Barney is like suddenly whole again when he gets that back.
Moby不能偷。
It's, yeah, I really loved rewatching this one.
Moby可能认为他是一个大，著名的明星，但他不能偷我的朋友和得到心理。
I really, this is a fun one.
而且Barney像突然完整再次当他得到那个回来时。
We didn't do a Christmas episode in season one.
它，是的，我真的喜欢重温这一个。
I can't quite tell you why.
我真的，这是一个有趣的。
Maybe it had to do with air dates.
我们在第一季没有做圣诞剧集。
Maybe we just didn't have a good idea for it.
我不能完全告诉你为什么。
We had a good idea for Thanksgiving episode and a good idea for a New Year's episode and a good idea for a Halloween episode, but we skipped Christmas.
也许它与播出日期有关。
I'm so glad we did a New Year's one.
也许我们只是没有一个好主意为它。
What I loved about the comment to begin this episode, I forget her name, forgive me, I like to remember her person's name at the beginning, Andrea, from Remind me of everything about Andrea from Mexico.
我们有一个好主意为感恩节剧集，一个好主意为新年剧集，一个好主意为万圣节剧集，但我们跳过了圣诞节。
Andrea from Mexico, I know, I just wanted to share what I was gonna write.
我很高兴我们做了一个新年剧集。
What I loved about her comment was that she says, she watches it every year right after midnight.
我喜欢关于评论开始这个剧集，我忘记了她的名字，原谅我，我喜欢记住她的人的名字在开始，Andrea，从提醒我关于Andrea的一切来自墨西哥。
I love that that's part of her tradition, you know what I mean?
Andrea来自墨西哥，我知道，我只是想分享我将写什么。
That's what she hits play on that, just like starting up the Punjabi song.
我喜欢关于她的评论的是她所说的，她每年午夜过后看它。
So thank you, Andrea, sorry, I forgot your name briefly.
我喜欢那是她的传统的一部分，你知道我的意思吗？
For Mexico, your comment was amazing.
那是她点击播放它时，就像启动旁遮普歌曲一样。
I love that it's part of your New Year's tradition.
所以谢谢，Andrea，对不起，我简短地忘记了你的名字。
We didn't do too many New Year's episodes, but this one, this one was a good one.
来自墨西哥，你的评论是惊人的。
I feel like we're actually up to the point plot-wise where Derek comes back and Ted is crushed.
我爱它是你的新年传统的一部分。
And I will say, I don't know, there was something, I really believed Ted's devastation when Derek hops in that limo.
我们没有做太多新年剧集，但这一个，这一个是一个好的。
Like there was something about my face that I was like, that was good film acting, Radner.
我觉得我们实际上是在情节wise到达那一点当Derek回来而Ted被压碎。
I'll see, I like hearing you say that.
而且我会说，我不知道，有东西，我真的相信Ted的毁灭当Derek跳进那辆轿车时。
I like hearing you admit that you've been good on this TV show.
就像在我的脸上有些东西，我当时想，那是好的电影表演，Radner。
I felt like, I really felt for him.
我会看，我喜欢听到你那样说。
I was like, oh, this is such a bummer for him.
我喜欢听到你承认你在这个电视节目上很好。
And the night was going particularly well, you know, for him, vis-a-vis Robin up until that point.
我感觉到，我真的感觉到他。
But I think he says the line, or maybe the narrator says all night long, I've been trying to chase something down that was right there in that limo.
我是说，哦，这对他是如此的糟糕。
Does he say that?
而且那一晚进行得特别好，你知道，为他，对于Robin直到那一点。
Yeah, it says.
但我认为他说了那句台词，或者也许叙述者说“整晚，我一直在试图追逐某种东西，它就在那辆轿车里”。
And it made me think about, you know, you really watch these people from their mid to late 20s to their early to mid 30s.
他说了那个吗？
That's kind of the arc.
是的，它说。
And it's a really pivotal time, that decade, 25 to 35, let's call it, is huge, right?
而且它让我想到，你知道，你真的从他们的中期到后期20多岁看着这些人到他们的早期到中期30多岁。
And there's a huge transition.
那是那种弧线。
And I think your 20s are really about chasing experiences.
而且这是一个非常关键的时刻，那个十年，25到35，让我们称之为，是巨大的，对吧？
That's why it's like, we have five parties to hit.
而且有一个巨大的过渡。
We're going out, we're gonna like go West, young man.
而且我认为你的20多岁真的是关于追逐经历。
Like we're seeking our fortune, we're seeking romance, seeking connection, you know, all of it, and it's out there, right?
这就是为什么它像是，我们有五个派对去打击。
Everything is outside of you.
我们正在出去，我们要比如去西部，年轻人。
But then maturity, I wrote this down, is realizing it's about what's inside you and what's in right in front of you, right?
就像我们正在寻求我们的财富，我们正在寻求浪漫，寻求连接，你知道，全部它，而且它在那里，对吧？
Like it's like there's not a better life lurking out there.
一切都在你外面。
It's like the universe is inside me and also the people I love are in front of me and it's best to be present with those people.
但然后成熟，我写下了这个，是意识到它是关于在你里面的东西，而且是什么就在你面前，对吧？
So I think that in some ways that's the moral of the episode, which is like, and Ted changes, Ted learns that in that episode because he's driving them all over the city and he says, no, the best party is right here.
就像它是……没有一个更好的生活潜伏在那里。
I loved Ted in that moment when he said that.
就像宇宙是在我里面，而且我爱的人也在我面前，而且最好是与那些人在一起。
This is as clear an illustration of it's about the journey, not the destination because they literally never get to their destination.
所以我认为在某些方面那是剧集的寓意，它是……就像，Ted改变，Ted在那个剧集中学到了，因为他正在驱动他们全部在城市里，而且他说，“不，最好的派对就在这里”。
You never get out of the limo.
我爱Ted在那个时刻当他说那个时。
It's all journey.
这是作为一个清晰的说明，它关于旅程，而不是目的地，因为他们实际上从未到达他们的目的地。
Yeah, it's all journey, but not the journey song.
你从未出过轿车。
Except for the not that song.
它全是旅程。
Sorry for the Lord.
是的，它全是旅程，但不是旅程歌曲。
Yeah.
除了不是那首歌。
And to be fair, it also would have worked great.
对Lord道歉。
To be fair.
是的。
No, no, I could, I could, you could make a case for that.
而且公平地说，它也本来会工作得很好。
But there's something.
公平地说。
Totally.
不，不，我可以，我可以，你可以为一个案例制作那个。
Because the shot through the heart really just works every time.
但有东西。
It just pops so hard.
完全。
It comes in at a million.
因为穿心的真的只是每次都工作。
I will say that I thought the last scene with me and Kobe was pretty perfect.
它只是每次都弹出得那么难。
Perfect.
它以百万进入。
The writing of it was perfect.
我会说我以为最后一个场景我和Kobe相当完美。
There was no fat on it.
完美。
it's just so simple and you have enough history fueling them at this point eleven episodes in where not much needs to be said it's like it's this you know and you could almost plausibly make the case let's say Ted thought it was a bigger deal than she did you could almost make the case like you could interpret that as romantic or not like it was actually we threaded an interesting needle there yeah it was enigmatic there was something charged to it it was there I love that moment.
写作它是完美的。
It tees up the entire rest of season one in the best possible way.
没有脂肪在它上面。
Pineapple kind of brought it back, sort of got those embers going again a little bit with Ted's recalling her and bringing this back up at him and a little bit on the back burner, the Robin thing for a while.
它只是如此简单，而且你有足够的历史燃料他们在这一点上十一集进去，哪里没有太多需要说，它是……这个，你知道，而且你可以几乎合理地制作这个案例比如Ted认为它是一个比她做的更大的交易，你可以几乎把它解释为浪漫或不……就像它是实际上，我们穿过了一根有趣的针在那里，是的，它是enigmatic有某种东西充电到它它是……我爱那个时刻。
And this is bringing it back forward and this launches.
它tees up整个剩下第一季在最好的可能方式。
I would argue this is a really good midway point of a season episode because it really launches the second half.
菠萝有点带它回来，有点让那些灰烬再次燃烧了一点与Ted的回忆她和带回这个在他说，有点在后燃烧器，Robin的事一阵子。
Yeah, yeah.
而且这是带它回来前进而且这启动。
It also made me feel like when I was watching Ted, really through the first 11 episodes, Like, I think there's a pattern, I don't know if this is like a, if there's a term for this, but I hear from a lot of people who say, oh, I was very dear friends with my husband.
我会争论这是一个真正好的季节剧集的中点，因为这真正启动了后半部分。
He was just in my friend group, but I never thought of him that way.
是的，是的。
And then you kind of like, you know, when the lights come up at the end of whatever, your age, you go, oh, this is the person I like the most and feel the most comfortable around.
它也让我感觉当我在看Ted，真的通过第一11集，就像，我认为有一个模式，我不知道如果这是一个，如果有一个词为这个，但我从很多人听说谁说，“哦，我与我的丈夫非常亲爱的朋友。
I feel like Ted's kind of like the prototype for the guy, like in your friend group that a woman eventually realizes is like the best and kindest guy and falls for him.
他只是在我的朋友群中，但我从未认为他那种方式。
But he's easy to overlook when you're on that experience hunt, you know?
然后你有点比如，你知道，当灯在结尾的无论什么，你的年龄，你走，“哦，这是我最喜欢的人而且感觉最舒服的人。
You kind of don't see that guy.
我觉得Ted有点像那个人的原型，比如在你的朋友群中，一个女人最终意识到是……是最好的和最善良的家伙，而且倒下为他。
And I think that's what he said in his first monologue, like that monologue in the pilot.
但他很容易被忽视当你在那次经历狩猎时，你知道吗？
Like, I'm not good at this stuff, but I'd be a really good husband.
你有点没看到那个家伙。
Yeah, yeah.
而且我认为那是他在他的第一个独白中所说的，比如那个独白在试播集中。
Once you realize it's not about getting the five parties, the party's right here.
就像，“我不擅长这些东西，但我会是一个非常好的丈夫。”
Oh my God.
是的，是的。
This is it, the party is here, you know?
一旦你意识到它不是关于得到那五个派对，派对就在这里。
And I think like they get so excited like when Marshall comes back or Lily gets back, because it's like it doesn't feel right unless they're all together.
哦，我的天哪。
And in some ways, this episode more than any other episode is the five of them are a gang, like they're an absolute gang and Robin has been fully folded in.
这就是它，派对在这里，你知道吗？
So yeah, I was actually, I was pretty delighted by this episode.
而且我认为比如他们变得如此兴奋当Marshall回来或者Lily回来时，因为就像它感觉不对，除非他们全部在一起。
I remember loving the script and it being a hard shoot, but I think it endures, like I think it was worth it.
而且在某些方面，这个剧集比任何其他剧集是他们五个人是一个帮派，比如他们是一个绝对帮派，而且Robin已经被完全折叠进去了。
We thought we were giving everyone the simplest shoot of the year, and everyone was cursing our names by the end of the week, but it was a good one.
所以是的，我实际上是，我被这个剧集非常愉快。
So we're up to our very special section, which I think I'm gonna amend this, Alec, but I'm just now going to call this Questions and Observations from a clinical psychologist who's never seen how I met your mother, and also happens to be married to Josh.
我记得爱剧本而且它是一个困难的拍摄，但我认为它持久，就像我认为它值得它。
I just cut out relationship expert, because I don't know, I don't know that she would describe herself that way, and I don't know that anyone could describe themselves that way.
我们以为我们在给每个人这一年最简单的拍摄，而且每个人在周结束时都在诅咒我们的名字，但它是一个好的。
way.
所以我们到了我们非常特别的部分，我想我会修改这个，Alec，但我现在只是要称这个“临床心理学家的问题和观察，他从未看过如何制作你的母亲，而且也碰巧结婚到Josh。
You know what I mean?
我只是剪掉了关系专家，因为我不知道，我不知道她会把自己描述成那样，而且我不知道任何人可以描述自己那样。
I'd be wary of a relationship expert, except Terry Reel, who's a very interesting psychologist, if you've ever listened to him.
方式。
But he's very smart about relationships.
你知道我的意思吗？
All right, we will amend it.
我会警惕一个关系专家，除了Terry Reel，他是一个非常有趣心理学家，如果你曾经听过他的话。
We will have amended it in our graphic as you are.
但他对关系非常聪明。
If you're watching this on YouTube, you removed and here she is the not relationship expert.
好的，我们将修改它。
This episode almost felt like a microcosm of a macro theme of the series, which I think is summed up by what Ted said at the very end of the episode, and I wrote it down.
我们将修改它在我们的图形正如你是。
So he said, you probably want to feel bad for your old man at this point in the story.
如果你正在YouTube上看着这个，你删除了，而且这就是她，那个不是关系专家。
Well, don't.
这个剧集几乎感觉像是一个宏观主题的微观，我认为是被总结由Ted在剧集最结尾所说的，而且我写了下来。
Not every night has a happy ending, but all of it's important, all of it's leading somewhere.
所以他说，“你可能想感到不好对于你的老人这一点在故事里。
And for sitcom, this is truly a metaphysical spiritual lesson.
好吧，不要。
we make plans, the unexpected happens.
不是每个夜晚都有一个快乐的结局，但所有它很重要，所有它领先某个地方。
We have a small degree of control and then there's a massive amount that's beyond our control.
而且对于sitcom，这真的是一个形而上学精神课程。
In this case, the traffic, Lily's feet hurting, Marshall forgetting his phone, not Moby, waving around a gun in the limo.
我们制定计划，意外发生。
But the message of the episode that I took home was to have faith that whatever happens, even if it seems absolutely awful at the time.
我们有一个小的控制度，然后有大量的量，它是超越我们的控制。
It is indeed all important.
在这个情况下，交通，Lily的脚受伤，Marshall忘记他的手机，不是Moby，挥舞着一把枪在轿车里。
It's all leading you somewhere, and that somewhere is where you belong.
但那个剧集的教训是我带回了家是拥有信心无论发生什么，即使它看起来绝对糟糕在当时。
And for Ted, the planner whose plans were undone, it still ultimately led to that moment that we were waiting for, that kiss with Robin.
它确实全重要。
And though this is only Episode 11, and I have just shy of 200 more to go, my best guess is the entire show is going on fold following the spiritual lesson in a very similar way.
它全领先你某个地方，而且那个某个地方是你所属的地方。
Wow, that's uh, but that's too good.
而且对于Ted，那个计划者，他的计划被撤销了，它仍然最终导致了那个时刻我们正在等待的那个，那个吻与Robin。
That's better than anything we've said so far.
而且虽然这只是第11集，而且我只有略低于200更多去，我最好的猜测是整个节目是正在展开遵循精神课程以一个非常相似的方式。
Could we just, Alex, reset it down to that one?
哇，那是……是的，那太好了。
It's just gonna be Andrea and Jordana.
那比我们到目前为止所说的任何东西都好。
Yeah, I think that's a good cut.
我们可以只是，Alex，重置它到那一个吗？
Cut out, everybody, cut out all the dudes.
它只是将是Andrea和Jordana。
That's such a great comment.
是的，我认为这是一个好的切割。
I love that she singled out that ending narration, and I love that idea of it's all important, which is different than saying it's all gonna work out.
剪掉，每个人，剪掉所有那些dude。
I'm happy with that wording and that narration, it's true.
那是一个如此伟大的评论。
It's all, it's important.
我爱她 singled out 那个结局叙述，而且我爱那个想法，它是全重要，它是不同于说它是全将会奏效。
It's not all good.
我很高兴与那个措辞和那个叙述，它是真的。
It's not all bad.
它是全，它是重要。
It's important.
它全不……好。
It's important because it's part of your story and it's the accumulation of those sort of story beats of your own life that lead you where you need to be or where you want to be or where you hope to be or where you never thought you would be.
它全不……坏。
But then you're happy there.
它是重要。
You know, it reminded me of something I'd read that said, like, never trust a memoir or a biography that doesn't have like some scandal in it or the protagonist doesn't look bad.
它是重要因为它是你的故事的一部分，而且它是那些某种故事节拍的积累，属于你自己的生活，领先你哪里你需要是，或者哪里你想要是，或者哪里你希望是，或者哪里你从未想过你会是。
Yeah, like any biography where it's just that's hagiography, right?
但然后你快乐在那里。
Is that like how they describe like the lives of saints like no one's that interested in reading?
它提醒了我一些我读到的，说，比如，永远不要信任一个回忆录或传记，它没有……一些丑闻在里面或者主角看起来不好。
How it all went great like we want to hear struggle.
是的，就像任何传记在哪里它是……只是……那是hagiography，对吧？
We want to and you trust a narrator When they actually Jason's really great at telling stories where he's kind of the butt of the joke Like he loves it when he has been humiliated like he loves telling those stories.
是那个像他们描述像圣人的生活那样，没有人那么感兴趣阅读？
I always admired that about him He's really good at telling stories where he doesn't look that great in the story, but him telling it is charming and you forgive him whatever his behavior was because he's willing to share it.
它是如何全进行得很好……我们想要听到挣扎。
It's almost like one of the things, this is going deep in the weeds, but one of the reasons that the Torah, the Old Testament, was a revolutionary kind of earthquake and narrative is because Every story of a people was written by the victors, and it was written about how great everyone was.
我们想要……而且你信任一个叙述者，当他们实际上，Jason在讲述故事时真的很好，在哪里他是……那种笑话的butt，就像他爱它，当他已经被羞辱时，就像他爱告诉那些故事。
And the Torah and the story of this little tribe that got knocked around is just one idiotic move after another.
我总是钦佩那个关于他，他是真的好在讲述故事，在哪里他看起来不太好在故事里，但他讲述它是迷人的，而且你原谅他无论他的行为是什么，因为他愿意分享它。
Like they really cataloged their own folly, right?
它几乎像那些东西之一，这是要去深在杂草中，但那些原因之一，那个Torah，那个旧约，是一个革命性的种类地震在叙述中，是因为每一个人的故事被写由胜利者，而且它是被写的关于如何伟大的每个人是。
And their own, and how they didn't listen to the law or this way, and they didn't, you know, And it's maybe it's endured because it's honest.
而且那个Torah和那个小部落的故事，那被敲打周围，只是一个愚蠢的移动之后另一个。
And it's not, hey, geography.
就像他们真正编目了他们自己的愚蠢，对吧？
It's, I think we trust people.
而且他们自己的……而且如何他们没有听那个法律或那个方式，而且他们没有，你知道，而且它是也许它持久是因为它是诚实的。
You, when I hear, when you list your accomplishments, you breed competition.
而且它不是，嘿，地理。
When you lead with vulnerability, you breed community, you know?
它是……我认为我们信任人。
Yes.
你，当你列出你的成就时，你繁殖竞争。
So I think, you know, even though Ted, sometimes you can go like, oh God, why won't this guy get it together?
当你带领脆弱时，你繁殖社区，你知道吗？
It's actually his superpower.
是的。
that he is leading with, here's another way I messed up.
所以我想，你知道，虽然Ted，有时你可以去比如，哦上帝，为什么这个家伙不能把它放在一起？
Oh my God, let me tell you about this night.
它实际上是他的超级力量。
I really put my foot in my mouth.
他正在带领，这是另一个方式我搞砸了。
Let me tell you this.
哦，我的天哪，让我告诉你关于这一个夜晚。
Future dad is the embodiment of this.
我真的把我的脚放进了我的嘴里。
Yes, yes.
让我告诉你这个。
Like it's all getting dinged up.
未来的爸爸是这个的体现。
And in some ways, that's actually, it's occurring to me now, it's an incredibly loving thing to tell your children when they're ready to hear.
是的，是的。
I'm an imperfect human being, your dad just grew up.
就像它是全得到叮当声。
But also, he landed on his feet and he did okay.
而且在某些方面，那是实际上，它正在发生在我现在，它是一个令人难以置信的爱的东西去告诉你的孩子，当他们准备好去听时。
So I think it's a great observation that there's a kind of microcosm, macrocosm thing going on here that Jordana pointed out.
我是一个不完美的人类，你的爸爸只是长大了。
Yeah, it's a great observation.
而且我也……他落在了他的脚上，而且他做了可以。
It's my wife's smart.
所以我认为它是一个伟大的观察，有一个种类微观，宏观的东西正在发生在在这里，那 Jordana 指出。
Your wife's really smart.
是的，它是一个伟大的观察。
She's really good.
它是我的妻子的聪明。
You should hold on to that one.
你的妻子的真的聪明。
Whether or not she's officially a relationship expert, I think you should keep her around.
她真的很……好。
I think she's maybe a really, I think she's really weird.
你应该持有到那个一个。
Whether or not she's officially your wife.
是否她是官方关系专家，我认为你应该保持她在周围。
And I was like, yeah, she's officially my wife.
我认为她也许是一个真的……我认为她真的很奇怪。
Back off, man.
是否她是官方你的妻子。
Well, that was super fun, Craig, going deep on that episode.
而且我当时想，是的，她是官方我的妻子。
I really enjoyed that.
后退，人。
I like that one.
好吧，那是一个超级有趣，Craig，去深在那个剧集上。
Yeah, it's a good one.
我真的享受那个。
Isn't it funny that we're gonna have favorite episodes of this show that won't necessarily correspond to our favorite episodes of How I Met Your Mother?
我喜欢那一个。
They're just like, the conversation, it led somewhere cool, right?
是的，它是一个好的。
Like it'll be.
不是它很有趣我们将会拥有喜欢的剧集关于这个节目，那将不一定对应到我们喜欢的剧集关于如何我遇到了你的母亲？
Himium episode was garbage, but this podcast episode was really fun.
它们只是……对话，它领先某个地方酷，对吧？
The circuits were jammed though.
就像它将是……
The circuits were jammed.
Himium剧集是垃圾，但这个播客剧集是非常有趣的。
If we can't get anything going, like we're just like the circuits are jammed.
电路是堵塞的，虽然。
The circuits are just jammed today.
电路是堵塞的。
Look, that's New Year's Eve for ya.
如果我们不能得到任何东西进行，就像我们只是……电路是堵塞的。
You're welcome, but for that turn of phrase.
电路只是堵塞的今天。
Yeah.
看，那是除夕为ya。
Well, we like to end our episode with some viewer listener male and we have a lovely letter today from Jessica and Craig is going to read it for us.
你不客气，但为了那个短语的转折。
Yes, this is lovely and a little conversation talking point emerges at the end of it.
是的。
So here we go, ready?
好吧，我们喜欢结束我们的剧集与一些观众听众男，而且我们有一个可爱的信今天从Jessica，而且Craig是要去读它对于我们。
This is Jessica from Jessica.
是的，这是可爱的，而且一个小对话谈话点出现在它的末尾。
She says, Hi, Josh and Craig.
所以这里我们去，准备？
Jessica here from New Brunswick, Canada, shout out to Canada.
这是Jessica从Jessica。
We love our Canadian fans and we love our Canadian characters as a plural?
她说，Hi，Josh和Craig。
I think we had a few over the years.
Jessica在这里来自New Brunswick，Canada，大声喊到Canada。
My husband Tristan introduced me to him when we first started dating and it quickly became a cherished part of our lives.
我们爱我们的加拿大粉丝，而且我们爱我们的加拿大角色作为复数？
The show holds such significance to us that it actually played a role in our wedding day.
我想我们拥有一些在多年里。
From gifting my soon-to-be husband a blue French horn to open the morning of the wedding to having Heaven by the Walkman play during our recessional Great Song.
我的丈夫Tristan介绍我到他，当我们第一次开始约会，而且它很快成为了一个珍惜的部分关于我们的生活。
You have to wait till the end of the series, you get to it.
这个节目拥有这种意义对于我们，它实际上在我们的婚礼日扮演了一个角色。
and the unforgettable moment of our bosses surprising us with a cameo of Josh during our heartfelt speech.
从赠送我的即将成为丈夫一个蓝色法国号角去打开婚礼的早晨，到拥有Heaven由Walkman播放期间我们的 recessional伟大歌曲。
I know cameos might seem like a small gesture to celebrities, but hearing Josh say, as Ted Mosby said, love is the best thing we do on our wedding day, was nothing short of legendary, captured beautifully in the photos and video footage of our reactions.
你必须等待直到系列的结尾，你得到它。
Please send us those, by the way, Jessica.
而且那个难忘的时刻关于我们的老板们惊喜我们与一个Josh的cameo期间我们的衷心演讲。
It warms my heart to see how both of you remain humbled and perhaps a touch astonished by the profound impact your creation has had on countless lives.
我知道cameos可能看起来是一个小的姿态对于名人，但听到Josh说，“正如Ted Mosby所说，爱是最好的事我们做在我们的婚礼日”，是没什么少于传奇，捕捉美在照片和我们的反应的视频镜头里。
My question for both of you is this.
请发送我们那些，顺便说一句，Jessica。
Is there a show or film series that evokes the same feelings in you that Himyum does for its fans?
它温暖我的心去看到如何你们两个保持谦卑，而且也许一点惊讶由深远的影响你的创造已经有在无数生命。
I eagerly anticipate this journey of dissecting every last episode.
我的问题对于你们两个是这个。
Please know that you both and Carter have conjured something truly spectacular, a treasure that will continue to resonate for years to come.
是否有节目或电影系列，它唤起同样的感觉在你们里，那Himyum做对于它的粉丝？
Thank you, Jessica.
我热切期待这个旅程关于解剖每一个最后剧集。
Well, thanks Jessica.
请知道你们两个而且Carter已经施展某种真正壮观，一个宝藏，它将继续共鸣在多年里去。
What a lovely, every part of that, being part of their wedding.
谢谢你，Jessica。
I love that you did that cameo.
好吧，谢谢Jessica。
Did you, I don't know if you remember doing that specific one years ago or not.
什么一个可爱，每一个部分关于那个，是部分关于他们的婚礼。
And did you know what was going to be part of a wedding?
我爱那个你做了那个cameo。
I don't, I'm, I mean, I get asked to do weddings.
你，我不知道如果记得做那个具体的那个在多年以前或不。
I always make a joke about being underdressed.
而且你知道它将要去成为婚礼的一部分？
That's kind of my, um, but yeah, I mean, I, sometimes they'll say, can you throw in a Ted Mosby quote, you love.
我不知道，我是……我的意思是，我得到请求去做婚礼。
And for me, that's like the one, you know, from, uh, for a wedding.
我总是做一个玩笑关于未着装。
I think that's the, the best one.
那是那种我的，嗯，但是的，我的意思是，我……有时他们将说，“你能扔进一个Ted Mosby引用，你爱。”
Yeah.
而且对于我，那是像是那个一个，你知道，来自……对于婚礼。
我想那是那个，那个最好的一个。
It's the whole series, right?
是的。
that if you had to distill the series down to one line, that could be in the running to be the one.
And I think there's different kinds of love, like we have that one word, but like C.S.
它是整个系列，对吧？
Lewis has a book called The Four Loves, right?
那个如果你必须蒸馏这个系列下到一个行，那个可以是在运行去成为那个。
It's like Eros and Philos and, like there's different, but I think love more broadly speaking is kind of how it may or not, because there's certainly friendship, love.
而且我认为有不同的种类关于爱，就像我们拥有那个一个词，但比如C.S.Lewis拥有一个书被称为四爱，对吧？
It's so much about friendship.
它是像是Eros和Philos和，就像有不同的，但我认为爱更广泛地讲是某种它如何我……或者不是，因为有当然友谊，爱。
It's mostly that, right?
它是如此多关于友谊。
In the end, it's a lot of dates, but the friendships there the whole time.
它是多那个，对吧？
Yeah.
在结尾，它是很多约会，但友谊在那里全那个时间。
Do you have pieces of art that live and take residence in your heart the way that Hemium has for these fans?
是的。
I mean, for me, I feel like what Jessica's talking about, and I think the feeling she's talking about can only be achieved through a franchise, a series, something that goes on a while that you can spend that much time with.
你拥有艺术片段，它生活而且采取居住在你的心，那个方式Himyum做对于这些粉丝？
Your favorite movie that's like an hour and a half long, two hours long, you can go back into that world over and over, but it's kind of always that one thing.
我的意思是，对于我，我感觉像是Jessica谈论的，而且我认为那种感觉她谈论的，只能被实现通过一个特许经营，一个系列，某事它继续一阵子，你花那么多时间与。
It's hard to replicate that what she's talking about, what a TV series can give you.
你最喜欢的电影它是像是1小时半长，2小时长，你可以在回进入那个世界反复，但它是一种总是那个一个事。
It's such a gift to get nine seasons to do a show.
它很难去复制那个它她谈论的，什么一个电视系列可以给你。
So for me, what comes up for me when she says that is like Star Wars.
它是一个如此礼物去得到9个季节去做一个节目。
The Star Wars franchise just getting to that stretching across my entire childhood into my adult life.
所以对于我，什么出现对于我当她那样说时是像是星球大战。
The Harry Potter books and movies give me some of that feeling.
星球大战特许经营只是得到那个跨越我的整个童年进我的成年生活。
And then sitcom wise, you know, what made me want of right sitcoms was was Cheers mostly the show Cheers Buffy gave me some of that in my 20s and led into the show and casting Alice and had again and it's funny I had one other thing that came up for me from her question was I just watched the Conan O'Brien Mark Twain prize show on Netflix which is great.
哈利波特书和电影给我一些那个感觉。
Is that where everybody brings their A-game in that Feral so funny I saw that clip.
而且然后Sitcomwise，你知道，什么使我想去写Sitcoms是……Cheers主要是节目Cheers，Buffy给我一些那个在我的20多岁而且领先进这个节目，而且铸造Alison Had again而且它很有趣我拥有一个其他事它出现对于我从她的问题是，我刚刚看了Conan O'Brien Mark Twain奖节目在Netflix，它是伟大。
Will Feral so funny watch it watch the whole thing it's It's all killer, no filler.
那是哪里每个人带他们的A-game在那个，Feral如此有趣，我看到了那个剪辑。
It's like everybody comes and brings their A-game because they love Conan so much.
Will Feral如此有趣看它，看整个事，它……它是全杀手，没有填充。
And why am I bringing that up?
它就像每个人来而且带他们的A-game，因为他们爱Conan如此多。
It's because watching that made me realize how much Conan O'Brien has meant to me from 1993 premiering at Dave Letterman's old slot.
而且为什么我带那个起来？
Dave Letterman, a lot to me too.
它是因为看那个使我意识到如何多Conan O'Brien已经意思到我从1993首映在Dave Letterman的旧槽位。
I wrote for Dave Letterman a few years after that.
Dave Letterman，很多到我也。
I wanted to write for Conan.
我为Dave Letterman写了一些年后。
Carter and I both really were angling to write for Conan.
我想要写对于Conan。
And we got, they were not hiring, but Letterman was incredibly lucky.
Carter和我两者真的都在钓鱼去写对于Conan。
and I love Letterman equally as much in a different way.
而且我们得到，他们没有在雇佣，但Letterman是令人难以置信的幸运。
But Conan, just watching the Netflix special about his sort of totality of his career, I felt like emotional watching it because I'm like this, I just feel like I've lived 30 years with this guy.
而且我爱Letterman一样多在一个不同的方式。
And I got this brief little intersection with him where he came and spoilers.
但Conan，只是看Netflix关于他的某种总量关于他的职业生涯，我感觉像是情绪化看它，因为我是……这个，我只是感觉像我生活30年与这个家伙。
It was a background extra and an episode of How Much A Mother.
而且我得到这个简短的小交叉与他，当他来到而且spoilers。
We will explain that more when we get to it many years from now.
它是背景额外在一个剧集关于我如何制作你的母亲。
And after that, he knew that Carter and I were big fans and he asked us to, we asked him to lunch.
我们将解释那个更多当我们得到它在多年从现在。
And so a few weeks later, we got to spend a couple hours having lunch with Conan, and it was just, I just had this feeling in watching it, I think is what Jessica's talking about, which is you just can't, not many things can give you the feeling that you spent your whole life with somebody.
而且在那之后，他知道Carter和我大粉丝，而且他要求我们，我们要求他去午餐。
You've spent years and years and years in this world or with this energy, and so I'm so happy that Hemium was that to her.
所以一些周以后，我们得到去花几个小时有一个午餐与Conan，而且它是只是，我只是拥有这个感觉在看它，我想是Jessica谈论的，它是你只是不能，不是很多东西可以给你那个感觉，那个你花你的整个生活与某人。
What is it for you, Josh?
你花多年而且多年而且多年在这个世界或与这个能量，所以我如此快乐那个Himyum是那个对于她。
What comes up to you for you of that?
什么是它对于你，Josh？
Like, what have I held with me this over cross, across such a long time?
什么出现对于你对于你？
Yeah, well, we've talked about the movie Sing Street, which is one of my favorite movies.
比如，什么我已经持有与我这个跨越如此长一个时间？
I've just seen so much of it.
是的，好吧，我们已经谈论过电影Sing Street，它是我的最爱电影之一。
I love that movie.
我只是看到如此多关于它。
I just re-watched that movie.
我爱那个电影。
I bet Elliott likes that movie too.
我刚刚重新看了那个电影。
Has he seen it?
我打赌Elliott喜欢那个电影也。
Ah, he hasn't seen that.
他看过它吗？
Yeah, that would be a great one to watch.
啊，他没看过它。
I think he.
是的，那将是一个伟大的一个去观察。
What a music movie.
我想他。
One of the great music movies.
什么一个音乐电影。
And great brother movies.
一个伟大的音乐电影。
Yeah, it just works on all levels for me.
而且伟大的兄弟电影。
Hell, I'll let you know.
是的，它只是工作在所有水平对于我。
I'm a huge fan of the before trilogy, the link letter.
该死的，我会让你知道。
See, that's a trilogy.
我是巨大粉丝关于那个三部曲，那个Linkletter。
Because you have years and years that spans 15 years, those three movies.
看，那是一个三部曲。
and you get to watch them age, which is always so moving to watch people get older.
因为你拥有多年而且多年那个跨越15年，那三个电影。
And I just think there's something, he really catches something in those movies.
而且你得到去看他们老化，它是总是如此移动去看人变老。
The last one's almost like impossible to watch in some ways, because it's so tragic, but also so beautiful.
而且我只是认为有东西，他真正捕捉了一些在那些电影里。
But I love those, I'm trying to think, I mean, there's certain authors that I, just I'm always coming back to, I've talked about this before, but Nick Cave does this weekly, it's called The Red Hand Files, And he just answers kind of like, reader, male, and he's, he's the most beautiful writer.
最后一个几乎像是不可观察以某些方式，因为它太悲剧，但也如此美丽。
He's really funny.
但我爱那些，我正在试图去想，我的意思是，有某些作者那个我，只是我总是回来去，我谈论过这个之前，但Nick Cave做这个每周，它被称为红手文件，而且他只是回答某种像是，读者，男，而且他是，他是最美丽的作家。
And it's reliably the best thing I read every week.
他是真的有趣。
And I feel like I get to sit around this campfire with Nick Cave and have him tell.
而且它是可靠地最好的事我读每一周。
He wrote one today that was so funny about him and Nick Cage getting confused.
而且我感觉像我得到去坐周围这个营火与Nick Cave而且拥有他告诉。
And he was drinking with this guy whose wife was leaving him.
他写了一个今天它是如此有趣关于他和Nick Cage被搞混。
And he was like, my wife loves you, man.
而且他正在喝与这个家伙，他的妻子正在离开他。
I need to tell her.
而且他是，我的妻子爱你，人。
realized he thought he was Nick Cage, the actor, not Nick Cage, the rock star.
我需要去告诉她。
So he ends up writing an autograph for her, and he ends up talking about raising Arizona was a tough shoot, but the Cone Brothers is so great, and he was so drunk, just imitating Nick Cage.
意识到他想他他是Nick Cage，那个演员，不是Nick Cage，那个摇滚明星。
But I love those so much, and I think the campfires I tend to gravitate around are a little more probably movies or books, but you know, I grew up watching Cheers and Family Ties and that, you know, that Thursday lineup, that night court LA law, I mean, so I feel, I watched so much more TV when I was a kid than I do now, much to my wife, Sugarin.
所以他最终写一个亲笔签名对于她，而且他最终谈论抚养亚利桑那是一个困难的拍摄，但那个Cone兄弟是如此伟大，而且他是如此喝醉，只是模仿Nick Cage。
But yeah, I mean, I don't think anyone gets in this business that we're in without having things that have really taken up residence in their psyche, you know?
但我爱那些如此多，而且我认为营火我趋向去引力围绕是有点更多可能电影或书，但你知道，我成长看Cheers而且Family Ties而且那个，你知道，那个周四阵容，那个夜法庭LA法律，我的意思是，所以我感觉，我看如此多更多电视当我是一个孩子当我做现在，很多对于我的妻子，Sugarin。
And I'm sure we'll end this, and I'll think of eight more in one of those.
但是的，我的意思是，我不认为任何人在这个商业那个我们在里面没有拥有东西那个已经真正采取居住在他们的心灵，你知道吗？
Well, I think you hit the nail on the head by saying the word campfire.
而且我肯定我们将结束这个，而且我会想关于8更多在一个那些。
I think Jessica feels like she was around this campfire with us for all these years.
好吧，我认为你点击那个钉子在头部通过说那个词营火。
We're all telling stories.
我认为Jessica感觉像是她是在这个营火周围与我们对于所有这些年。
And I think it's such a gift to have that campfire kind of burn for as many, for enough years to sort of tell enough stories around.
我们全部正在告诉故事。
And I think it's so rare to get to do that.
而且我认为它是一个如此礼物去拥有那个营火种类燃烧对于多……年去告诉足够故事周围。
That's why my brain went to like things I've spent lots of time with.
而且我认为它如此稀有去得到去那样做。
I think that's what she's talking about.
那个是为什么我的大脑去到像是东西我花了很多时间与。
So yeah, thank you Jessica for the question.
我认为那是她谈论的。
Thank you for spending that much time with us around the campfire.
所以是的，谢谢Jessica对于那个问题。
And this new campfire too.
谢谢你对于花那个多时间与我们围绕那个营火。
So thank you.
而且这个新营火也。
I am guilty, please equip me.
所以谢谢你。
All sins are forgiven in New York City.
我是有罪，请装备我。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas and is presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
所有罪被原谅在纽约市。
This episode is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
如何我制作你的母亲是主持而且执行制作由Josh Radner而且Craig Thomas而且是呈现而且分发由那个Office Ladies网络而且Odyssey。
The show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
这个剧集是也执行制作由Jenna Fisher而且Angela Kinsey。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
那个节目是制作而且编辑由我，Alec Lev，而且我们的合作制作人是Doug Matica。
Our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的音频制作人而且混合器是Alex Reeves在Point of Blue Studios。
Artwork by John Morrow.
我们的数字内容制作人，aka Gen Z大师，是Emily Blumberg。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
艺术品由John Morrow。
That really does help the show.
请跟随，评估，而且审查那个节目在Apple播客或你的播客播放器关于选择。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
那个真正去做帮助那个节目。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
我们的主题歌曲是纽约市由我们自己的Josh Radner与额外音乐由Craig Thomas而且Andrew Majuski。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
特别感谢Lola Kennedy而且Elliot Connors。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
访问HowWeMajorMother.com去学习更多而且点击在那个联系页面去发送我们一个电子邮件或一个语音消息。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at joshradner.com.
你的故事而且问题是一个重要部分关于那个节目。
Order Craig Thomas' debut novel, That's Not How It Happened, wherever books are sold, and check out his other published writings at CraigThomasWriter.com.
订阅去Josh Radner的时事通讯在Substack而且检查出他的音乐而且一切其他在joshradner.com。
And you can subscribe to my own Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
订购Craig Thomas的处女作小说，那不是如何它发生了，无论书在哪里被售，而且检查出他的其他出版写作在CraigThomasWriter.com。
To learn more about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign, to raise money for congenital pediatric heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
而且你可以订阅去我自己的死父亲协会，也在Substack。
People will, in fact, dance.
去学习更多关于如何你制造一个差异，这个节目持续运动，去筹集钱对于先天儿科心脏疾病研究，检查出那个制造一个差异标签在顶部关于我们的网站。